all right
and we are live the last word friday
evening campfire
with lord ibontis been a while feels
like it's been a while but it hasn't
but but the reality is we got some uh
maybe some special royalty in the
building what's going on oh we got a
great guest joining us tonight but
before we get started
i just wanted to let you guys know this
is our last episode for 2020. not going
anywhere we're coming back in 2021
post new year's but the way the holidays
fall christmas and new year's literally
are on fridays
so we're going to take a little break
just to let you guys that know that up
front also to let everybody know who is
listening to this one i'm going to give
you guys this warning now this is going
to be a mature
audience podcast just because there are
some passionate topics to discuss
tonight and we want to make sure it is
uh just open and free so you can say
whatever you want tonight
that being said if there are children
lock them away or listen to this
in your own ear not to the public family
viewing
all that all that out of the way let's
get this thing started
so as we wrap up our third year of doing
this podcast i just want to thank
everyone who has ever listened to us
chat for 130 episodes and to all the
amazing guests that we've been lucky
enough to share some time with
we've been going since all the way back
from curse of osiris and we've been
going
uh and we have been going long enough to
see his return twice
we appreciate each and every one of you
that let us fill an hour or two of your
time
it means a lot that being said we have
an episode to record tonight so let's
get going
welcome to the last word episode 131
snow has graced the tower and the
dawning is live
and we have an amazing guest joining us
tonight to discuss an interesting week
in destiny to say the least
for this girl gaming has been a passion
for a long time now
but bungie made the gamers version of
bangers and mash
when they put wow and halo together and
dropped it into this into this world
on her birthday since then she's become
a very special piece of this community
and a guide and teacher to so many and a
mama of titans in this universe of light
and dark
with over 700 raid clears and literally
over a thousand hours
in destiny 2 raids to [ __ ] to say she
knows her stuff
is an understatement one could say she
is a sherpa but that doesn't quite do
her work justice
by the time someone is done playing with
her they will understand all aspects of
the rage
and has experienced all facets of each
encounter so they can actually go teach
others when they go on
so let us introduce in proper last word
campfire fashion
a woman whose career is currently
strapped to a rocket is a member of clan
pinnacle
and last rites partner with sneak energy
guitar slayer
screamo teacher leader of the body
positive movement in the destiny twitter
community
reckoner in 32 hours lover of synthwave
and knows the true meaning of linguine
hailing from the united kingdom ob katie
cat welcome to the campfire how are you
doing
i'm [ __ ] amazing and that just
full-on caught me off guard
jesus bloody christ you know you [ __ ]
we gotta introduce you right and you got
a long list accolades so it was worth
shouting out as many because i could get
out
welcome how are you doing how are you
doing i'm i'm doing great like
full disclosure for everyone that's in
chat like i was literally saying to
these guys before
right um i i genuinely thought this was
gonna be a 3am
um and then just by a whim checked my
dms um like what 20 minutes before this
um and was like okay i'll catch up with
everything and then soon
the discord damn someone was like oh
[ __ ]
that's like the main reason i basically
got no face on and stuff like that so
yeah you look great i'm chilling i'm
chilling
good to have you long overdue know the
schedules and everything well we're glad
you did check
so that we could have you here yeah a
lot lot going on so we gonna jump right
in right
so i was gonna say like um just in
general like you know looking over your
gaming history and stuff like that
so some cool varied history you know
little pokemon
little you know different thing world of
warcraft and stuff like that but what
would kind of like the
some also some of your other earlier
influences just in gaming before destiny
um i would say it'd
probably be like because i remember when
i first started gaming it was all like
it was it was very early games you know
there wasn't any like a super advanced
stuff like so
my like i was like playing pokemon and
all that but then when the ps1 came out
i was playing the likes of
alien yeah i know i was way too young to
play it but no i appreciate that one
though that's a good one
um yeah the the og alien
um you had um the original resident evil
you had um abe's odyssey
are you excited for the new one i'm
gonna see if i can find the clip later
like when i got announced i literally
seen abe's face and was like
and then ps2 comes out and i'm like met
alarms glitching the system
um all that kind of stuff um and on the
xbox i was playing like
time splitter portal
absolutely and then you had like all the
halos
come out and then obviously like halo
was something that i fell in love with
but all these games kind of like led
me towards like it was either
well when they announced destiny i was
like [ __ ] yeah this is what i've been
asking for
um totally right but like if it's not
him if it's not destiny then it is like
adventure like really really bold
storytelling ones like the likes of abe
and time splitter and stuff
and paul um i was gonna say i saw you
oh you've got horror yeah i saw your
play through horror of course
i appreciate any horror game likers
because there's not a lot of us out
there who want to
you know have the hair stand up on the
back of our neck but
i liked when um it was
a sea of solitude when you played that
one i saw the way that one hit and it's
just like
gaming is one of those things when you
get those type of moments whether it
it's the fact that it can make the hair
stand up on the back your neck and also
make it just like hit you just like
absolute gut shot and gaming's been
pretty cool thing so it's good to see
somebody whose experience
did that as well oh yes so well done
so well thank you very okay i am gutted
that i will never get to play hellblade
or sea of solitude
for the first time ever again like those
two games
specifically right so sea of solitude
gave me
like i'm probably i'm gonna play that
again because just to you know
re-jog the memory and like remind myself
that like all these things are like
you know things that everyone deals with
and all this kind of stuff but
that for the first playthrough really
got the brain
self-reflecting big time and like being
like oh
[ __ ] um and then the ending obviously
like literally me and chat once the
credits are rolling we just had to like
literally just all have a cry together
um
but in terms of hellblade let's talk
about it
like so this is the thing hellblade when
hellblade 2 got announced
i think it was at the it wasn't the game
yep games
x with the series x announcement yeah
all right
so hellblade 2 gets announced and i was
like that looks awesome what's this
and chad's like the tailblade hellblade
was awesome and they're all like
spamming like [ __ ]
hellblade was sick yeah and i was just
like
i haven't played it i've never heard of
it it's completely gone under my radar
and then chat and then like literally
one of my mods was like
i'm getting used to i still haven't
played it actually so i need to
i do like i know i need to i know how to
play um
one of my mods i think it was kai
specifically um kai got me it
i was just like right okay and i was
like how long is it and they're like
it's eight hours about eight
ten hours long yeah um and i was like
right okay
so if we just put it on hard as
difficult you go through it start to
finish and
like because we've been playing destiny
we've done everything we needed to do
today we've done like
raid runs and all that and i was like i
was like okay
chat george george just do a full play
through now just [ __ ] it we've been live
for like seven eight hours already
but you want to just go for it and then
we're just like yeah yeah so we just
literally changed it
went through it and [ __ ] me got to the
end and i
like it's changed my perspective of
story games i think forever
because it is so well done
yes that like every other game just
looks
so inferior in every way since
i'm just like oh my god so that's why
i'm so glad that cf solitude really like
hit me in a different way because
it was different and it wasn't coming
from the same angle that
hellblade was yeah so completely
different it can hit me in a different
way but like in terms of just
story games full stop that should do
it's kind of ruined them for me now
in a good way yeah but i mean that
obviously that's now on my radar
honestly it's kind of one of those like
if i know two has a date that's one of
those where if i can like
play one to be fresh and then go into
that it actually might work pretty well
but you gotta do it because i i agree i
agree
it's like you like she said it it's the
i don't want to spoil too much because i
want your experience to be new
yeah but it's the it's the use of sound
in such a unique way
and it is a great job for the first time
for me in gaming
of of handling and showing how mental
illness can affect people
and um it is it it's really amazing
it is it was very ambitious the first
one you know from a small team
so i was kind of excited now that ninja
theory you know they've got the full
backing of microsoft now they're gonna
have
like what they were able to do prior it
to me is just
mind-blowing it is something yeah it's a
very unique experience and a cool thingy
like you said if you plan on doing it
you know um
yeah before you it's like you know eight
to ten hours about you know but
you're gonna be on the edge of your seat
like you're gonna i'm looking at you
just saying i don't think i've cried so
hard after seeing solitude since
like watching marley and me i'm like
okay dog movies in this game like i'm
going to be like a weep-a-thon over here
then
because yeah that's good right sir
you've all you've seen the placer of cf
solitude didn't you i just literally
all i literally watched was your little
clip where you had to like where you
were trying to decide to hit the trigger
so i know no context to the game i just
know i saw that one moment
through the acceptance clip that was all
i saw so i actually don't
have a clue what got you there or what
was happening i just like how that one
moment where you did not want to hit the
button
because it was that impactful which was
awesome so
again that game also seems pretty big if
it's going to make you do that so i'm
i haven't watched it if you if you ever
decide to do that game
play it either with someone in voice
call
or with your chat there really yeah yeah
do not play that game on your own it is
it is a lot it's a lot it's a lot like
hellblade you can hellblade's all right
to play like probably it's just depends
how stable you are
really yeah but but in terms of sea of
solitude
like i've i have spoken to
guardians mental health since playing
that game well
yeah that game really makes you think
and it is [ __ ] incredible like
but me like wow well nice to add a
couple of
editions all that um and then
now especially especially now
back for blood came out in the alpha
yesterday oh
let's have you played it no i have not i
saw you playing and i was just
excited it is so
[ __ ] good it is [ __ ] incredible
like that
for an alpha stage game yeah pretty much
like
four levels and there's like there's
basically no bugs
it just runs smoothly the gunplay feels
amazing it feels amazing to do the run
over and over and over and over and over
again because the zombies don't spawn in
the same place there's different waves
different makeup of waves
and ah the glock
i feel like i want to say it's face off
with maybe nicholas cage
might have like an extended clip like
full auto pistol like that i've always
thought those are awesome
that's cool um like that that game just
every time i was i was going through
just made me more and more excited to
jump into it when it's full release
comes out
now you do you come from the left for
dead camp like what do
were those your titles right i wasn't
like i loved them but i never got too
deep into them because i had card
zombies that basically it was like
the same thing but like because everyone
was playing card it was easier for me to
get into
absolutely um and like that was the
thing like cod zombies was always my
thing
like i got caught but i didn't play
i didn't play pvp yeah
so when i've done i'm
like got card or anything like that or
halo for example i'd play the story in
firefight if it was zombies
i uh it was called i'd play zombies with
destiny obviously it's raids and pve end
game
and law hunting and that kind of stuff
and
my favorite thing is to just get [ __ ]
stupidly powerful guns
and just shoot hordes of things which is
why like
it's why i like the hive so much
um like like literally just just dlc
after dlc of hive i'd be
happy
you just need to see it through so you
can excite me like that i can only get
what like [ __ ] out
no honestly like the way the lore has
been going the hive have been the big
like puppet master in the back with
savathu and they've been the big evil
outside of whatever the darkness
question mark if it's good about or
otherwise
the big deal has been the hive for so
long that it's always seeming to be
the next thing that's going to be there
so no it's like so
yeah i'll get to one later on i'll save
that a little bit actually
no but i want to know like 100 is like
hot like my thing is like
you know big intense stories
and shooting hella things we're actually
going to be jumping into doom eternal
series i've never i've never actually
played a tunnel oh
we played doom 2016. i've played that
but i never got around to eternal
because
i can't remember what i think a destiny
dlc or something had dropped around the
same time most likely
and then i was just like okay i haven't
got time to do it so
well like the chat's been telling me to
do it um obviously like
it's funny because during the back for
blood we were actually um
blasting the damn soundtrack because
like the game soundtrack itself is
really good
but like it kind of like it only plays
for so long it's quite quiet in the
background but it's still like quite you
know it's quite melty it gets quite
pumped
um but the doom soundtrack to play like
ollie oh it is something else my brother
actually
his son is playing it right now he's
like hey he's playing it but he just
said he'll go in
to like where he's playing it he'll just
like head bang for a minute
and just kind of like mosey on out but
yeah he's like he's playing through it
right now no i've i haven't touched
eternal yet 2016 was a ton of fun though
yeah a ton
ton of fun always destiny keeping us
from other games
oh yeah it was like when dlc came out
damn that's why i didn't play
well well that's the thing like
literally um
i was saying this to i think i think i
was saying it to chat yesterday or when
i went on my run
um which you know we're going to be
going into
but like i'm already done with beyond
like pretty much
like i've done pretty much everything
the only things i've got to do is like
you know the time gated stuff which is a
whole other [ __ ] issue
and any anything that's not that the
only things i've got to do
now is like i'm not going for conqueror
because i've already done it and
there's literally no point in me doing
that again just for another version of
conqueror that's just counterproductive
and time wasting to me personally
um and then try uh
trials i've already got flawless but the
adept weapons with the state of
pvp i'm not going to get into it because
i don't enjoy pvp anyway so i would put
myself
with that um like [ __ ] l cheaters
last season's more bad enough
like i got heavy carried to get to
flawless last season at the floor seal
because we got that
that was the only sale that was standing
away from getting them all uh and then i
had a lot of pvp folk
basically carry my ass through it like i
was doing i was doing i was doing a
teams up with like the likes of benny
and all them kinds of stuff
and they were like full-on like going
for it they were like no you need to get
this this is like
if that's like all you were missing
that's awesome you got people that got
you there
yeah yeah you've gotten one of those
seals completely on your own and
32 hours the thirty thousand i can't
believe you still did that
reckoning in 32 hours is wow yeah like
because
like we started it i had the weapons
because the weapons were the only ones
that were time gave but the armor
was the only like i didn't have a full
set of any of the armor
so i still had to do that um
and i still had to do every single
triumph
and we were like right okay chat do you
reckon we could do this in like
a day or a weekend so we started it
and did you sleep
in between start and finish no no no no
no no no
she's crazy wow
we did um like i love doing stuff like
like that's the thing that's why i hate
time gated stuff so much because if i if
like you know if that's there like i
literally turned to chat the other day i
was like well it wasn't even yes
yeah it was before we did um the day
before we did backflow when i was on my
rant
like literally i was i was sat there and
i was looking at the
like what i can do in destiny which is
nothing because
i've done it um or you're waiting on it
yeah well it's not even that because
it's all tedious stuff it's nothing
challenging
um like the only things we've got left
to do are
the well i've got to do a three-man
flawless of the raid
i've done three man i've just not done
three my flawless then it's then
my clan's onto two man and then two man
flawless that's that's the three things
i've got to do left this season
and prep for next season that's it i've
done everything else
and i'm farming for roles i have
tomorrow won't drop and every heritage i
guess
[ __ ] garbage so i'm like well
it's not rewarding for me to do a run so
why am i going to just
do that like yeah i'm fine teaching
people and all that kind of [ __ ] but
there's only so many runs i can do like
i'm i'm
nearly on 60 runs now yeah and i'm
taking it
slow wow that's slow
and i'm surprised the eyes depart
tomorrow didn't drop yet
yeah well you're listening i'm sure yeah
but like
literally i'm looking at the sales and
that and i'm like okay so
we did everything for um for
you know the descendant title um which
is the deep stone one
yep um we did everything for that like
rapid like that was done um
but then i'm looking at it and i'm like
right okay so it's got challenges to get
or and
eyes of tomorrow those are the two
things i need to i've got three weeks of
challenge left
and get a nicer tomorrow that's all i
need to do but that seal
i'm in terms of uh is it shattered or
splintered one of the two
maybe yeah i can't remember yeah for
that it's actually okay so
i've got to wait for stuff to come out
and yeah that's eve
that's if i keep up like literally i'm
losing every time i'm logging in i'm
like oh okay can i do this and then i'm
looking at the list of things to do and
i'm like
it's smaller i just i just can't be
bothered like it's
it's so it's it's not even it's not even
like it's hard it's just
tedious to keep up with and i'm just
like where am i up to
i don't know i might do i care no um
and then i'm looking at all of the seals
this season like that and i'm like
nothing interesting which is not
interesting whatsoever
um so i'm looking at that and then i'm
like oh
what are the games let's oh
and then the fact that [ __ ]
hawkmoon's role is a time gate is like
excuse me but
yeah what is what is that i didn't want
to get your thought on
many things tonight but as you said that
one
no time restriction as i said yeah you
can ask uh
no but whatever it's just like random
stuff exotics like
what do you what do you think about that
for both of you guys
i'll let you go first oh um random wrote
yeah i don't i don't know how to feel
about it it's um
it's unique i mean i never i've never
think they would kind of like go this
direction you know obviously
you know with hawkmoon and stuff like
that but um i guess the question for me
is whether or not
this becomes something they you know
make a pattern of you know i'm saying so
right now i'm feeling like it's
something exclusive to um
to hawkmoon but yeah i don't know how i
feel about that i don't know how i feel
about it because it's like okay we could
have
two exotics you know and minds
functionally
operates different you know i'm saying
from yours so
you know you got to be i think you got
to be careful you know with how how far
that scale is how how
what's the differentiators that's to me
that's the thing so yeah man i i don't
know it's like
i got i got to see this implementation
first you know but it's definitely new
territory
no i didn't think they would do
something like that so i'm very very
curious about it what do you think again
right okay so i remembered where i was
going before we were talking about
hormone as well
um a little bit of a tangent talking
about long stuff that i can just
dedicate an entire thing
i'm saying can we do an entire title in
in like because i was like that was the
whole reason i was looking at titles i
was like
can i do this title in a full in the
rest of stream no
okay next one no that one no that one no
and i'm like
right okay well i can't do any of that
and then i was sat there thinking about
like
we need a community event and obviously
the dawning's a thing but it's
right it's it's we'll talk about that
later yeah
i'm pinning lots of stuff in terms of
like corridors of time
right that was [ __ ] amazing to do i
remember being like when we did that
um and then serif towers as well like
when we were talking about this is this
is why this came into my head
because when we did seraph towers um
that was a 67-hour stream
wow we had three hours of sleep in that
like
not much we used we used cha like
basically i'd go for an app i'd put an
afk macro on and try to just join
on each other so that we kept the
instance going and kept like making
progress but we got everyone in our chat
to about 400 clears and the eight of the
top 10 people
were in my chat including myself yeah
i'm
okay thank you for that apparently yes
well see i'd say thank you but then like
literally like you look at corridors and
like we stayed up like the entirety of
that
and it's like everyone hates bastion now
so
except hercules he's definitely a fan so
i like that i like that she goes
like i i i i love bastion but at the
same time like everyone like when they
come across like oh [ __ ] bastard i'm
like i'm sorry
yeah the way it was acquired was better
than
the way it is but like yeah um
but then as well like felwinter's door
as well that was a
that was the thing and then people are
missing out on it now so like you know
i don't get why that's not a like it's
not a
iron banner pinnacle but we're not gonna
yeah
oh why why is why is young wolf or iron
lord not a title that is
something well this one's literally the
iron lords podcast so believe me he
wants the iron lords title more than
anybody i know
all of them yeah man i guess it's so
cool like
did that did that involve i thought like
sally it almost feels like he's not
part of destiny sometimes now like they
they should
really involve a title with iron banner
especially with the way they treat it
they bring it back all the time
so it's not like you're gonna miss it so
you know street like how they treat
trials trials has a title um
i can't even remember the original
question by the way so what was the
question again
you remember um tangents are fun we went
on facebook with all three tangents
chad do you remember what was the
question we need you chad
we need you random roles
that was it thank you um
yeah no as long as it's specifically
just hawkmoon
i feel like that'd be okay because you
know it is a hawkmoon
at the end of the day um the
my concern with it
is how often is it going to drop from
the mission
because currently i don't know about you
but doing
12 18 12 50 lost sectors right
the drop rate for those is [ __ ]
abysmal
talk about it so like i'm there trying
to farm i've been trying to farm for a
god roll helmets ain't 14
for years right
still haven't got the perfect draw i'm
trying to go for a
20 uh 20 plus intellect and uh
resilience role still haven't got it to
this day
and everything else in my armor i've got
like
two or three things in either in
resilience and intellect and then
potentially a recovery
but those two specifically in either mid
to late 20s or even
30s on all my armor except my helmet
14. and it is driving me
[ __ ] nuts
well like literally the same with cloud
strike cloud strike's meant to drop from
this [ __ ]
you know this this uh empire empire hunt
took me about 36 runs to get the [ __ ]
thing oh
just get back and i'm like right okay so
if hawkmoon is anything to go off of the
rng of any of these other things to get
stuff
then it's going to be like a 1 in 50 run
to get
a [ __ ] drop and then what
what are the what are the perks that you
can get on it because then
that's a whole other situation because
if the if the perk list is like
like at least even if you got like bare
minimum like
five things that's just
nutty five and then it's a case of well
if you get duplicate drops if you get
this that and the other and you're just
like
if it's that bad then why in the [ __ ]
would anyone do it like sun is better
anyway like people just want to go to
the hog moon because it's a [ __ ] hawk
moon and it goes kaka
so you know it's one of those i'm that's
my main concern it's like what's the
drop rate going to be like and what's
the perk set
yeah well as long as they don't get it
into all the weapons it should be okay
but like if they start doing on every
exotic then they're just going to end up
with a [ __ ] nightmare
yeah because you can't pull it from
collections then yeah
yeah it'll it's probably going to give
you the base one right well
because they can't give you around one
over that's all you can pull
yeah i think the big thing as you said
keep it to this and i don't know if it's
like
you used to have the randomness of the
bullets in hawk moon they're like hey
we'll have some random perks but as you
said
what if it is like you can run it once a
week maybe per character so that's three
and what if there are like you can get
different you know a couple two or three
different perks on this thing
let me start going to five and you said
five okay so here's five
this times five is 25 times 125 times 6
25 and you're like
i'll take one and then i'm good because
then you make the grind not worthwhile
like you're just like i'm trying to get
everything's the same and i'm just
trying to get one perk
and i can just sit there and grind it
out if i want to maybe but even then
i guess like everybody's like look at
the heritage role everyone's going for
at the moment
literally corkscrew assault mag
reconstruction recombination with
handling
right that is the god roll
and in all of these runs i've done
the closest i've got it's all of those
except assault mag
you still get a pretty good one yeah you
got clothes you got clothes now
oh come on now all of them except
instead of recombination
um i've got a moving target
and i'm like these two are good on their
own
yes but you compare it to the guard roll
yeah they're in the [ __ ] bin
anyway it's it's it's like husko like
i'm still trying to go for a god roll
who's going but at this point i don't
[ __ ] care because rockets just
[ __ ] [ __ ]
rockets yeah they didn't they got they
got
one to two more in reserves and they
changed the reserve nothing else nothing
else
not real not like hey if it's like we
don't want to worry about maybe reload
faster or two in the chambers what
everybody would love and they just will
not do it
and i don't know honestly the main thing
that i'd save like
right now for me especially with this
community event is literally if they
make the last engram like a year three
version of galley or something like that
oh oh they just did isa tomorrow though
do you think they'd actually even
consider that
it's all right but it's it's that's the
thing they will net like the aesthetic
of golly and the sound
it's like as of tomorrow is pretty ugly
looking i have to admit
as good as it is yeah it's just it looks
like
i i do not look at any rocket launchers
in d2 apart from you know
truth or not i think it's called battle
miss
come on now bad ole miss it's not that
bad looking what's aesthetically
detailed
it's just like i'm playing but that's
the thing though that is the thing
with me i know i know you guys have seen
how my
fashion within destiny is it's it's
better than his
oh watch your mouth oh
it's different shades of brown it's
leathers it's
you know it's like worn kind of bronze
armor stuff like my titan wears bro like
wears a brown
shader and all that kind of stuff i wear
the ornament with the helmets 1814 with
the like scratches and dints out of it
and
okay all that kind of stuff i wear the
titan mark which is like
the the original titan one from uh the
campaign where it's got all the rips up
it and all that kind of stuff
i like that because it looks like my
titan from d1 but it looks
weathered whether thank you you've seen
some [ __ ]
yeah yeah like my titanium my titanium
d1 pretty much has the exact same armor
set
as my d2 titan it's very very close the
only difference is i've now got the sun
break
gauntlet on instead of the moles molars
um
instead of the vog legs i'm wearing the
sun break legs
um but i wear this prodigal chess piece
instead of the iron lord
uh the night chess piece because you
know
it doesn't exist but it literally just
looks like it's been worn down
that much that you know the iron lord
stuff isn't on it anymore
this helmet feelings dented and
scratched and all that my marks all
torn the it like the gauntlets literally
look like moles moles has just no longer
got the [ __ ]
thing on it yeah um but but it's still
like you know
pretty similar um and i'm looking at
that and i'm like
oh gorgeous
she's like that way it looks like then
you look something yeah you're like you
look at the majority
of the armor that's out at the moment
and you're like
it's too over the top it's
like yeah okay people like the glowy
stuff but like
for me personally um as much as i would
like the age of triumph stuff
armor-wise at the same time i personally
never used it okay because
i was more into that is my titan
right and god damn my titan looks nice
i don't need all this glow and stuff
it's not tactical or efficient to wear
glowy gear if you're going into the
likes of
you know you go into you know crota's
end and you're fighting against thrall
in the dark and you're still there
[ __ ] looking like they're blow sick
like they know where you are it doesn't
make sense
i always wonder about that in pvp too is
like i wish you could like have a shader
swap before a pvp match be like i want
to blend into the background and like
camo my way through the matches
supposedly that's what i mean
yeah it's why i wear brown it blends
into most environments
yeah um but no it's it's i don't know
i'm seeing that and then like obviously
they're like
bringing out the dawning sets that
are just again it's another really spiky
fancy over the top
and shiny and i'm just like right okay
so no matter what shader i put on this
it's still gonna look like it's gonna be
over there
you get a lot going on are you a fan of
the a lot going on
yes all of it give me it all right oh i
want to shine
let me shine let me get my colors on
cause y'all don't use
colors
this man's color choice actually now you
mention it
now you mention it there is an exception
to how i see it
okay right okay so on a hunter if you're
wearing celestial nighthawk and your
supers charged
those eyes in the dark oh boy that is
terrifying
and the other one is if you are a
warlock and you're wearing this season's
ornaments with the uh and you wear the
shader which makes the eye green and
you've got the eyes
on your arm and then you're going to
grab something you got the chronic grips
on with the
see this is a woman this is what i'm
talking about
fashion the problem with you tight you
don't some of you tight not all of you
but the problem is you got to you got to
expand you gotta get outside you know
your comfort zone you gotta mix it up
that's what's fun about destiny you
gotta have fun with it yeah
i gotta stand what i can i'll i'll mix
things up i could go through quite a few
though
what you did recently was just oh it's
fine questionable no no
it's a very questionable fashion choice
it was great oh so basically blue
and red like rule up on him but it was
great
it just did not look right and
somebody's like oh i love that and i'm
like
yeah they just see a quick animation of
his hand in a little clip i'm like what
are you doing oh it's awesome
oh i can't it's awesome i'll show you a
picture yeah it's awesome so it's uh
it's arctic pearl
i'm going with that yeah
you gotta mix it up you can't be coming
in with the
basic line all the time every you know
you gotta you gotta switch it up so this
is my darkness ensemble for the fall
you know what i'm saying arctic pearl
you got the blue and then you got the
red so i'm showing you a little
corruption you know what i'm saying
like i'm fighting i'm trying to be good
but i'm fighting it
see it's it's dramatic it's dramatic got
it we got to rock with it
oh who said newport regal reef made is
my joint who said that
you know black wings expanding horizon
is fine
but you decided to wear the colors of
the horizon
listen man it's fly i'm getting a lot of
copy oh let me tell you i got so many
compliments in the tower
they were like are you lord see are you
that i love that if people would go up
next to the emote in the tower
i love it when people do that like i'm
literally just sat there or i'm running
around
like my favorite one is when i'm not
even doing anything like
yes if like like like yeah sure if i've
matched with someone on a strike and it
happens it's like
oh yeah hey but if i'm sat there talking
to chat i'm not even looking at the
screen
like half the time i'm even chat can't
see the screen
but like like i'm just talking to these
guys and
they can see in the corner of my eye
someone [ __ ] emoting and i'm like yep
all right so funny and then like
messaging in the local chat saying
you know [ __ ] oh my god it's cat hi i
love you
and i'm like so cool yeah it's so cool
baby i love you too and then you know
back
tea bag a little bit jump off the edge
you can't be pushing them off there no
no they're not pushing them off the edge
me jumping off yeah
oh okay okay
i got you shout out to the chat all
right so i'll sandy okay if you want a
good shader for that i read that
get that harmonica i think it's called
um yeah get that one if you like red and
black do that
and then who's in there bird bro
so like gambit emerald is one of the
ones i really like i got waffles cameron
jade stone's really nice for that that
was good
that one is really good for the warlock
helmet that's the one it basically makes
it look hive
mm-hmm like have you seen my warlock i
have not
right i'm gonna i'm gonna send it in the
in the chat here so you used to but ue
black armory rasmussen that green yellow
it's like a green yellow brownie kind of
thing but the green is a very thin
yeah that if you like it it's a
different look i like it all my weapons
too
mix it up for the fall i'm finding it
for you
now
wait for it
oh that almost looks like aeris actually
that's legit yeah that's not like that
you got the necrotic grip then you got
the arrows evolved
yes with the hell with it yeah that
looks good
that's dumb that looks damn good i like
that is a warlock to me and then
obviously my titan
is let's see if i can find it
uh we did a photo shoot totally see this
stuff right now
picture a warlock that looks like
like purple and gold he loved anything
leviathan
some of those look good some of those
look good because like the purple if the
purple was like a deeper purple and the
gold was it like blah
then it was like i like the the shiny
accents with like the deep purple
yeah some of those those were good [ __ ]
about if you don't be quiet and put up
your guardians so i can see all this
or cognitive take some lesson you need
to put your guardian up so i can see
what you your fashion look like i
literally
look like stasis right now in my titan i
thematically i gotta see that i look
like i
see what what what which picture let me
see what's going on
yeah you i can't i'm not logging into
the game right now i got enough going on
my computer i could probably do it
but i'm not doing
if you guys go follow cognito yes
on twitter and go look up his go look up
his warlock
somebody tell me i'm crazy somebody tell
me i'm crazy it's fine
go look at this go look at him
[Laughter]
anyway as we're looking over shaders and
stuff like that i'll let you go
um it has been an interesting week in
the world of destiny we'll start with at
least the feature of the week before we
get to
all the drama the donning
which is gonna kind of lead into sun
setting because that will get there
um but just wanted to get you guys
thoughts on the donning the aesthetics
the rewards
yay anything exciting everything kind of
blah
what do you guys think upstairs that
there was one thing which excited me and
then it was
it was like you've got me excited and
then you just
completely dried me the [ __ ] up because
um
literally right okay so it came out
within
a couple of hours we'd finished the
dawning um apart from handing a cocky to
zer
that is all i've got to do left and have
done since a couple of hours after it
launched
um and was like all right
then i received where the cold front
could drop with
dragonfly let's go it was like a kinetic
with dragonflies
let's [ __ ] go let's go
and then when you turn around and like
oh yeah that's a bug
and like literally i've got reports of
my chat when they've got a dragonfly
role they're shooting something getting
a head shot and it's not blowing up
because
it technically can't explain and i'm
like
yeah well that's just taken any sort of
fun that i
was looking forward to out of the event
i agree and i no longer care
and then was just like i ain't doing it
now
because there's like like because you
look at avalanche
as well the fact that the power level is
still
wow that that's another thing nicole
from
the cold front 1260 the what you that is
weird what is that about what you're
saying
no it should no that'll be 14 10 a new
drop should be
my cold front is 12 whatever well but
it's the fact that it's the exact same
gun as last year and you've got to
refarm the role that you had
yep yeah that's my issue it's just like
it's like why why just farm for the same
thing like i was literally saying this
in my run
i was like oh yeah so
in terms of sunsetting right when they
were all saying you know
sunset is coming this that and the other
i was
greatly in the
department of no this is a good thing
let us try it out i am excited they've
said this will
now allow them to go and make stupidly
overpowered weapons because they will
have a lifetime
they will be unique they'll be you know
[ __ ] insane
they will allow you to bring you new
fresh
paints to guns that we have not seen
before the new types of weapons that we
haven't seen before because they have a
lifetime the likes of mountaintop would
well
specifically mountaintop because i
remember thinking this because i was
like yo
mountaintop is the perfect example of a
gun that is [ __ ] insane
is so much fun and we'll have a life
cycle so it won't be a problem for too
long
and then i am banner gets announced and
it's the same [ __ ] as always
[ __ ] you look at the loot pool
there's nothing in it granted they
brought stuff
from a couple of seasons earlier to add
to the whirlpool
but i've already got all that if i'm if
i'm not a casual player i'm going to
have
all that already so that takes that off
my list of
[ __ ] to do and then i'm like right okay
so
i've got this i've got that there's
literally
nothing of any of these different
loopholes that i want because i've
already got them or i've had them in the
past and i no longer give a [ __ ] about
refarming a role i've already had
because that is tedious
and not worth my time i could go and do
something else
and then i'm like right okay
so basically you just give me a big
middle finger bunji
and is is it because i'm not a casual
player is that is that the whole reason
behind this
is no and i i know that is like a
hardcore versus casual argument and
that's something completely different
but at the same time i i it kind of
feels like a backhand it's like you're
most your most loyal players that like
you know understand the gameplay enough
to know it inside [ __ ] out
and are able to like you know do
something as fundamental as running a
strike
in under like two three minutes um
versus someone who's able to do it in
like 20 minutes
and because
those players that haven't got
everything
they can't speed run stuff they can't do
this on the other they seem to focus
more on that
and then everyone's left with like [ __ ]
all to do we're all twiddling our thumbs
and then we're like they're going oh
okay we want this we want that you know
they're the same they want feedback they
invite us all to
you know community [ __ ] summits and
[ __ ] like that and they're like what is
it that we want
and then so we tell them and it's like
oh we're listening
and then
well we'll get onto the article in a bit
[Laughter]
agree with you because i wasn't sure
about the avalanche coming back
but my issue with avalanche i have my
feeding frenzy rampage
mag or ricochet rounds and i have my
long zoom scope
uh medium zoom and i'm like but feeding
frenzy rampage on a machine gun i'm like
i'm solid same thing i had all my
hammerheads those are helpful
and i'm sitting here and like yep that
one is maxed out at 1060. i'm sitting
here
i get a new one there are newer perks on
it sure
some of them could be beneficial but i
have one i'm happy with and i just can't
use it and that's
right that's the big issue is like it's
a backhand
it's a huge backhand and the fact that
you can't use it but it's in the
loophole and you've got a grind for a
new one it's just
[ __ ] stupid and that's the thing is
what you've got like the um
here's something as well that i was
looking at it's like you look at the
raid machine gun
right it's basically just hammerhead on
stairs
but every other machine gun in the game
is far inferior to it
like literally if you can get wreaking
uh reconstruction on any weapon
any weapon you could yeah any weapon in
the same archetype
as that gun is
it's just been because reconstruction is
that good
but that's the thing i was expecting
you know i wasn't exp well i was
expecting
the entire loot pool including the
europa weapons
right to have stuff like the likes of
reconstruction
right do we have that
let me ask you this you know you know
not a fan of thresh you're not a fan of
chain reaction
i i mean they're all right does it help
me melt the boss faster
not particularly wow tough crap
here's the thing right my stats right so
my
my the loadout i use if i'm not using
double shotgun or a shotgun with a
sniper
then i will be using my iklos smg
which has demolitionists and uh grave
rubber on
nice so my and plus bear in mind my
stats as i said before
no matter what armor i have in in terms
of my armor which arma sunsetting should
not be a [ __ ]
thing bungie yeah yeah
because like you know we've farmed for
that armor specifically
put my materials into the thing yeah
yeah exactly and if they're making
material
you know material rewards like why why
in the [ __ ]
would you want to go out and farm all
that again but you know that's another
thing
don't know what you did um like
just opening you up right here away
uh no matter what armor combination i'm
using though
my recovery no my my intellect and my
resilience
is always over a hundred no matter what
set i use
so i've got that my demo my my my
discipline is like maybe 10
10 or less but because i've got um
because i've got demolitionist on my
icoloss doesn't matter i can just go
my recovery is 50 to 60 usually
um so you know i'm always regening i've
got the likes of protective light i've
got
you know resists and all that kind of
stuff um
and i've got um was it recuperation
on my legs which allows me every time i
go over an orb of light i'm getting
health back
um and then i'm obviously using um
global reach yes
yeah well i don't use anything other
than that on the war mine cells because
but that's simply because i use that
specifically to detonate a
you know an entire thing so usually my
loadout would be
either the new raid sniper or the new
rage shotty
with uh i coloss
uh first and last out i love that so
it's one of those
so it's one of those um or
a well you got you've got risk runner
which i used on day one
um out and then i use either a little
mint falling gain
or um what's it called
or you know xenophage or anarchy that is
always my loadouts there is nothing else
that i need in a loadout they cover
every single base
that i need and when it's like oh i've
farmed for these perfect rolls and all
these things
just to go oh that gun's gone now that
armor's
gone now but it's
in the loophole as a new thing and
you've got to farm it all over again
yeah that is tough that is a
huge no-no
on my behalf and i seen it and was like
i don't [ __ ] think so
well sir what are you thinking on all
this stuff i know i've gone off on armor
before
they literally talked about it in the
previous discussion from
joe blackburn when he was talking about
like
looking into armor and having it more
than just be like hey let me replace the
stats that i already have every year
like we've i've been down that road and
it's like i completely agree just kind
of curious your thoughts on
like new perks and mods and all the
stuff that's going on because you were
asking about some of those so where are
you at on
what we have to choose from or go for
quick one
um also going back to the hardcore
thing it's not just a hardcore that i
know suffering from it
i've realized this because i'm t you
know obviously like you said earlier i
teach a lot of people i do
i do play with a lot of you know various
backgrounds of players
and once you've taught them the raids
they go off and do it themselves
and there's only so many runs of that or
you know they're in
our chats who you know they're asking
what weapons to go for what this to go
for what that to go for and
after it not dropping or after finally
obtaining it
there's only so many times you you can
do something before but
before the casuals on are in the same
situation as the hardcore because
they're all sat there like well
why in the [ __ ] am i gonna do this
because it's gonna either get sunset or
it's not worth my time
and yeah i i i just realized because
like literally there was someone who
started playing the game
like not long before the online they
started playing with me
basically completed beyond light already
and they're like
i was casual going into it got hardcore
and then that's the thing though like
because we've all been in covert and
stuff like that people
are better at the game people have been
watching streamers people
like they've they now know the game
better so
even these casual players the ones that
only play like a couple a day
a couple of you know a couple of hours
in a week they still because they've
been watching streamers and all that
kind of stuff they've
or like they've been able to get a
little bit more time in or they've
they've played the game for [ __ ] long
enough to see
you know what's this that and the other
um
so now they're like burning through
stuff and like it's like kind of one of
those so it's like jesus [ __ ] christ
like something needs to change and
sorry go ahead are you the author
you enjoy the rants this is this is your
platform to
vent outside of many others that you
have
yeah for me like it's it's i understand
everything you know you guys are saying
for me
you know i actually the only thing i
differ is i actually like
the perks this season i think um they
introduced a lot of cool new ones i
thought
i'm really a fan of chain reaction um i
think that's a really good good perk um
there's a reload perk
that i mean it's not better than auto
reloader but the one that gives you the
two
bullets um thresh i think is underrated
they kind of curb it with the super
depending on how much super you have
is how much you get but um i thought
that was cool
but um yeah i actually like
reconstruction as far as
um a perk as far as a raid specific perk
because i've always complained that
raids don't have their own
identity from their legendaries always
raid legendaries and destiny 2
when was just very generic so in my
opinion
you know that reconstruction is a good
step in the right direction now where i
agree
with both of you is the loophole the
loop pool is a problem
you know and the problem is when you
sunset and you gut
all these weapons out you take all this
stuff out
you know then you better have an influx
to put in and i think that's the problem
that was so and they've acknowledged it
right they
they understand they've gutted so much
out and you look at situations like
avalanche and you look at situations
again with 450 machine guns and stuff
like that there's
you know once hammerhead was sunset you
know a lot of other whatever 450s other
machine guns or whatever from um
menagerie whatever it really didn't
leave you with a lot
so that right there is a problem and i
do agree with katie cannon's sense of
you know it doesn't feel good to do the
dawning and you're seeing
avalanche come back again to you know to
form the same role
again like no one's really trying to do
that
now again i grew a kitty cat the thing
that excited me is when people found out
about
cold front you know when cold front i
was like oh wow that can run with
dragonfly
that's unique that's cool let's get in
there
right i'm about and then the minute
we say that oh budget makes you say oh
you know
that that's not how yeah we didn't
intend that and i'm like
well it would be so cool like my thing
is how is that
hurting anybody by leaving it
you know what i'm saying like that
that's my thing it's like it's 750
the kinetics don't run you know
dragonflies for the most part
and it's a good archetype it's a rare
archetype so that bothered me that they
they were they want to be quick to um
to get rid of that you know kind of
thing so that took you know that took
incentive away i'm not gonna lie
and i'm not gonna lie either like i
what's the the fusion with the c
crypto whatever cairo that i'm not thank
you
for that oh god the glacier did you see
that
i missed that literally literally first
package that i opened
of the dawning right i got one of those
fusion rifles
um and literally
the role i got was um
full ball accelerated coils killing wind
high impact reserves
oh wow okay that was the first package i
opened and i was like ah okay well
there's me done and then that's when
chat turned around and was like
oh you can get dragonfly and cold front
and i was like holy [ __ ]
kinetic with dragons this is this is
delving into [ __ ] fatebringer type
territory where
that's the exciting thing yeah that's
why i was so excited i was like
that is [ __ ] unique that is going to
be [ __ ] awesome
that is the one time that i would
potentially go
my colossus smg's yes saying for a bit
because yep
a connecticut dragon is [ __ ]
awesome it would it'd be so [ __ ] cool
and then they turn around and go oh yeah
no it's a book no and it's the same with
every
everything this season that has been fun
right
thanks wait we gotta give craig come on
now we gotta get thrown in the crowded
grip come on we gotta give him
the cry [ __ ] yeah okay there you go i'll
give you that one i'll give you that one
okay all right here you go there it is
um
but in terms of pretty much everything
else
that has that we have found in terms of
like you know the stasis launching
in terms of like launching yourself
across the map using stasis if you use
the bite right button combinations and
all this kind of stuff
uh like that is the only thing i enjoy
on a hunter like i don't
you guys know i'm i am not a hunter by
any stretch
but but being able to go like 500 miles
an hour
from standing stationary with a world
line and
and shatter dive or even a well of
radiance in shatterdive
seeing how fast i can kill those
characters using that
and launching myself across a map is the
most fun i've
ever had on a hunter and you're on my
warlock as well
um it's it's not as fun
but it's still rapid but
um no yeah shatterline hunter
is oh there is nothing like
you're just sitting there like we're
doing the raid and i'm just literally
there like hmm
there is a rafter up there i can land on
that
then i can hit the roof at just the
right angle
and if it goes wrong i'm gonna die um
yeah but then they're like oh yeah that
that that's uh
that's going away like oh you can farm
about like because i don't know if you
know but when beyond like came out we
did the stuff we focused on like my team
specifically focused on
story day one and get as many power
levels and as possible day two go for
completing your
season pass like that was again get from
a season rank whatever you're on at the
end of the story get that to 100 by the
end of that day
and we did that um and then
day three or four when do you turn
around like oh yeah
um bounties on moon boundaries on europa
xp is like significantly less yeah and
it's like
you've just taken the fun like that is
the thing if you if it's the same
situation as when izanagi's got nerfed
right
it's a case of i know this is a whole
different thing but
if there is a gun that is capable of
using the likes of hot swapping between
and izanagi's
reload cancel into a autoload and
grenade launcher
dump swap back to izzy's keep doing that
in a cycle that takes skill
to do maybe maybe there's an argument
there that oh
it's not that hard too but at the same
time knowing the game enough to do that
kind of stuff
there is a large percentage of the
community that don't know about that
kind of stuff because it's not
it's not the straightforward thought you
know just
press press forward and sprint and swap
weapon at the same time
to you know get the animation off faster
like that is not
a a straightforward thought process but
then when we figure out about it
it's like oh this is sick and you use
stuff like that with combat
like combining debuffs buffs all this
kind of stuff on top of each other
you've got like
um you know like using tractor using
divinity
and they go okay so you've got these
debuffs and buffs we're going to make it
so that justin
yeah it's only the top one so you can't
stack them so there's literally no point
in
coordinating your team to do that it's
like okay so izanagi's is too good
you're able to melt bosses using
coordinated skilled teams
and using you know coordination and that
kind of stuff
oh you can do that oh not anymore we're
going to nerf nic izzy
oh what's this you can dedicate an
entire you know if you literally spend
the time which is an
entire day mind you to complete a season
pass which is extremely tedious and
background stuff anyway
oh what's this we don't want you doing
that we're gonna take that away
so all these things that are so much fun
the same with you know being able to
[ __ ] hot swap between two one two
punch shotguns and then throw a throwing
hammer
and get that to five times five and then
you can nuke a boss
that's not easy to do especially if
you're in end game
activities where you've got hordes of
ads coming at you
you're at a disadvantage because you've
got two shotguns on and they're throwing
hammer
do yeah you're not set up for a lot you
have like one specific
purpose that's your purpose and it is to
nuke a boss as fast as physically
possible
and you look all that stuff and it's
like oh okay yes it may not be working
as intended
but it is [ __ ] fun oh it's fun oh
absolutely
the issue what we've seen and it started
i would say all the way back when
everything that gave
us supers like right
that's when i started to see daddy
bungee come out
and daddy bungee don't like us melting
bosses
doesn't like us having our super back
pretty much all the stuff that we find
fun
daddy bungee says no yeah it was like
you'll like that let me know it was
for you it was what's the helm oh
skeleton
car school of dire home cara and then
that was the most
fun that was like the most fun version
of a void lock i've ever seen
oh i had so much fun yeah double bars
all over the place oh it's fine
but if phoenix protocol caught that
renegade same thing yeah and then they
even kind of get did the same to dune
marchers
and ursa not quite to the same extent
they weren't quite as powerful but still
the same idea is
hey you built a thing that lets me get
back super hey there's a point where
there's a crap ton of guys that i can
get back my super
you literally made it actually now that
you mentioned regen and stuff right i'm
really hoping they don't crack down on
what i've managed to do but i can get
right foot
forward might want to not tell them no i
i shared it on stream you know that i
was saying that i have built my
my titan specifically to fight my
playstyle
right it may be for half a second
and it's like literally i have to be
really [ __ ] quick at doing this
what if i am able to be in the middle of
ads and stuff
um and have the focused fist
proc which is every time you do melee
damage you get class ability stuff back
uh if you use a class ability around
enemies you also get your stuff back
using my class item
as well as when you use your class item
you get class item energy
yeah and i have a hundred resilience
barriers in mind
it goes straight into it for for half a
second
i can get three barricades up at the
same time nice
nice that's terrible i'm looking at that
and i'm like i really hope that they do
not
have possibility again because that is
stuff like that is what i
really [ __ ] enjoy because it's like
okay people see one barricade it's like
oh okay
people see two barricades at the same
time from the same titan
oh [ __ ] imagine seeing the third pop-up
you're like all right
like i pulled it i pulled it off on
stream the other day and chat was
like holy like yeah
that's nice that's pretty cool yeah
that's getting nerfed now by the way you
can thank
yourself for that hundred percent of
your policies yeah that's the end of
fun and that's one
like the way you phrase that is one
thing i hear
some people truly say it's like there's
our fun
and just like it's like a nails out they
just keep hammering the fun down and
it's
it's like if you're not playing the game
like bog standard 20 minutes to run a
strike
kind of level then yeah yeah and if you
know if you're not spending day one kind
of levels of time within it within a
raid then
you know what then good
i'm sorry no you're going to try i i
i started to notice it even if you look
at the new strike everything new that's
been introduced right
from uh a boss fight or a strike
standpoint
when you do glassway right everything is
phases now
everything one second everything is fake
you because
even when you fight or you're fighting
the the other chick
everything they stop you right at the
point cause they know
the player the hardcore player they're
going to nuke
yeah we're going to figure something out
whether it's you know
i mean they gave us lament so that's
their own fault with that one but it's
foreign i don't know but i'm waiting for
it to not be
amazing it is that is potentially one of
my favorite exhausting day too yes
see and i'm not just because just
because of the fact you can nuke with it
oh aatrax is literally a [ __ ] show
without always so funny i've seen no fun
with that gambit damn that's a problem
david is just a blast i've
literally saved teams with just me
coming through with a little bit and
tearing through it okay continue
i love it i absolutely love it
literally yes like whatever they've done
with gambit as well i just want to say
like gg
it is really fun to do yes
like the the only time i've ever had fun
in gambit since the launch was the 32
hour reckoner
um like that was actually really fun i
did not rage or anything like that
during that i
thoroughly enjoyed that um because it
was like you know it was condensed into
that it was
it was like physically able to do in
that time and it wasn't
that challenging to be perfectly honest
it was just a case of dedicating
my mind to doing it um
so we did it but then like there's no
reason to do it
like i go into gambit now just for fun
before i've got nothing else to do
yeah i go in when literally we're there
with lament like i'm
i'm a um sentry player okay okay oh wow
we do the same thing
so like literally but like here's my
strap right i go into gambit i pick up
five notes i go back to the thing
i bought it oh my gosh exactly like me i
don't go after them
i get the five and i go back and then i
go and i use
yeah so it's it's it's it's a sniper
with a shotty with lament and it's
literally just a case of
go out get the five notes bank them wait
for them to
kill them my team banks all those they
start draining whatever moats that
they've put in
to send their blockers over i go through
and invade
so i like do like a century invasion
type thing i go through i snipe them get
rid of all their moots come back and
kill any blockers out there and it's
just a constant cycle of that
and it is nuts and then like literally
we get the but we get the bottle we've
all got lament ammo then because we've
all been doing the waves
and then it's just a case of where you
were
kill kill once again
avoid buff as long as if it's the
meatballs though i've seen the meatball
more the meatball gets annoying with the
dog
well for starters look up at the boss
when you swing
um okay it actually does track a little
bit
or if there's any boxes at boxes or
trees or anything nearby just literally
just do that and then start swiping when
you're like
like you're like three quarters of the
way or pike wise
and just go light light heavy and then
as you do your heavy attack you'll like
kind of do your overhead and you'll drop
back to the floor and then the envoy
should spawn you throw a void need pop
the shield kill them and then just
go back up so so let me ask you from a
very efficient machine i love this this
is efficiency and i i need to learn this
level of efficiency so when you're
when the meatball comes out right you're
saying just
that it tracks so should i stay
stationary because what i was doing i
was jumping and getting smashed
underneath it
right so just stay up and then look up
and then hold up hold my sword
yeah literally go underneath it lock up
and then just start swiping oh thank you
thank you glorious because it's the same
way it's the same with um
with morgus oh okay oh yeah
a couple more yes that's right you just
have to look up morgan it fixes the
trucking
oh you helped me survive that was my
only thing i always struggled with like
aerial like say if a anti-barrier server
that was in
a strike and you got to you know it's
moving around that was the only thing
limit would give me a problem because i
was like damn it's in the air and it's
moving
you know how do i deal with it but now
that you're telling me to look up i can
say oh it's on now
oh it's on now they're gonna get it
honestly it's
three lights and a heavy while it's
revved up and it's the best sounding
because it's limit i mean
this sounds like a ten hit cardboard
that's what i've heard so many places
because they showed that in
the vitals like the audio stuff which
audio designer's coming up with some of
the craziest stuff to make the sounds
that we've had in game which is cool but
yeah when i saw that one then you heard
that and i was like that's a sped-up
version yeah that's that's
that's a chainsaw so i love it
so you go back to that outside of lament
and all that fun if you look at what
they've been doing
if you if you play your all of your role
permissions with pretty much every boss
as soon as you get to a certain part in
empire hunts it is
it's literally just damage gates and
it's [ __ ] damaging
it teleports it does it's they're all
doing this and especially the glass way
with the two
vectors things like that i will say
something about glassway to be honest
right okay so well to be fair then
there's two new strikes the new version
of omnigul
right with novota i really do like that
i do like that one as much as it's
frustrating that you can't nuke the boss
it is also a nice fresh take i
i remember going through the entire
strike the first time sat there
cosmo was in my chat and he's just
chilling he's just like you know like
what do you guys think and we're like oh
yeah it's [ __ ] sick
and we're running we're running through
disgraced
and because we were like okay we're
burning through europa now let's just go
and do a strike
yeah did it
and it was sat there i'm like this is
literally just it's just going to be
[ __ ] reskinned omnigul isn't it
just literally that and then we go into
the room and half the [ __ ] world's
missing
all these different things i was like yo
yo this is
sick and there's a slit that goes down
when they come from
yeah literally that is like the most
interesting yes eating strike yeah
but like you look at that and you
literally the only problem that i have
with that strike is the damage game but
you know it's not that bad she shows off
for like half a second she's spawning in
her woodland
she [ __ ] off again it's basically just
cali uh
[ __ ] uh cali 2.0 like let's just
smack her a couple of times and she
[ __ ] off
yep um but in terms of
glassway we did
um glassway on
the nightfall which was week one
we did the 12 50 nightfall oh boy
severely under leveled i think i think
we were like i think feel like 12 20 or
something like that
yeah that week yeah because we because
we were 12
30 like 12 30 going into week two
um because we we were like we were like
kind of burning through power levels but
also like we're just like
uh i don't want to go too heavy with it
if i can hit 12 30 by the end of week
one then i'll be 12 50 by the end of
week two
which is when the raid comes out so i'm
not really too bothered because 12 30 is
where we need to be for the raid yeah
for the rate
um and i remember we literally went into
the 1250 glassway
and that is the most fun i've had in a
nightfall
really ever specifically when i'm
specifically when specifically when i'm
on the level
because we went in um i was using bubble
as usual because i'm a bubble babe i
used that
throughout the entire game uh no matter
what
um i was using that um
with my barricades coming up every 14
seconds
um so i'm there protecting my teammates
um
you know we had um what was it we're
like falling getting
we were using um at the time with a
horde was broken
um so we were using that with iclos smgs
and first and last outs all that kind of
stuff
and just shredding i thought it was like
really [ __ ] fun shredding because
we're sat there and i'm using nikolas
with auntie
and uh auntie barrier your appearances
got the overload minotaurs showing up so
some of my teammates are using you know
like
um they're using like well so they've
got the solar need that they can
overload yes because we can because
that's the thing we completed our
artifact
like that week as well so we because we
did the
season pass in day two so we had the
artifact done
so we were like sick and literally going
into that kind of activity
right like i wasn't really bothered
about the rewards i was like i just want
a [ __ ] challenge
like honestly but going through that we
didn't really die
much to be honest we were like this was
just practicing for
you know the raid that was yet to come
yeah
i was going to say the pit the
radiolaria gauntlet worth you where you
have to like sit on the platform for so
long
oh lord that is so fun no no no
it actually wasn't that bad really no it
was literally just a case of let them
let them come to you i would put in a
bargain because we were two warlocks and
me
oh
and it was literally just a case of i'll
put a barricade left shoot with a hold
on the right hand side so if anything
comes near my barricade they're getting
stunned because i've got a helmet saying
14 on
and then like if anything gets close
it's a case of bubble yeah
she represents my warlock rift there on
the bench
and i love to hear
like literally it's a case of barricade
gets close to now um as soon as my
barricade recharges i put one on the
other side and then i've got
a barricade left and right you've got a
rift here and then you've got a wither
hold there and then you sit behind that
in a bubble mm-hmm so like literally
nothing can get that is getting through
let's get through yeah and you think
about this you're doing this like 30
power levels under
and it's just constant bombardment and
we're still pretty much speed running it
because it was just a case of stuff's
coming out okay anything's getting close
where the horde melts it
as um or my air gloss is generating warm
mind cells and warming cells are
irrelevant to power levels so you just
nuke everything
they're like i'm done
what about what about the the vector
yeah
we're gonna talk about but what about
the small vex that goes inside the thing
to chase you
how i was dealing with that which one
the oh number is two
the big boy and then the little hydra
the little hydrogen be coming through
he comes through he goes after you
inside if you try to hide inside the
building
yeah well you got the wyvern the thydras
i love that name uh yeah there's like
the big
boss and then there's the baby boss the
baby boss oh the little
oh no that was literally just a case of
like literally put a shield up and then
you'd have one person
go through the back side and two people
go the other side
and you just bait it with weather hordes
and you just go with a horde with a hole
with a hole over there
and it just goes down i see these these
these one percent tactic
[Laughter]
okay i was like how is she dealing with
that okay now it makes sense
and then got removed so we just swapped
towards the naggies and it was still
pretty much the same
thing like okay okay but like like it
again it's it's it's one of that
like it was so much fun to just be able
to go in and just like
get shredded but also should write all
the things
um that's a nice thing that's a nice
level though
when you can do damage but things are
also lethal it's kind of a fair
trade-off
like that's the thing that's what day
one felt like to me that's what that's
what end game
should feel like not like grandmasters
grandmasters are a little
too yeah you do [ __ ] all but the enemies
can one shot you that's yeah
that feels really wrong wrong
yeah but then in day one raids
like literally so as as i've just been
explaining there our main thing on day
one was survivability
that was what we wanted to work on it's
what we have been working on
and literally in the day one we were
getting like less than i can't remember
how many deaths we got throughout the
entire run but we were
not going down much um on our day one
run i will check for you now
um but in terms of
you know just generally like staying
alive
it was a case of oh okay so we know what
enemies do this damage we know
the you know the result of you know
getting the getting damaged by these
things yeah none of us died more than a
hundred times
on day one almost was
uh it was me at 94 actually
but everyone else was like the the
person who like died the least was 86.
yeah you guys are all pretty good so we
were more wipes than anything
so it was more wipes than anything
because we were like oh okay we're not
three-phase in it wipe
that's what we were like on day one we
were like okay we're not three foot
because we that was the thing we took
day one really casually like we were
just [ __ ]
we were just like gonna go in we're
gonna have a good time if it goes well
it goes well thank you right
yeah we're gonna end up in the
casual what the hell is hardcore for you
this is the thing we would go we were
going for like 10 minute breaks like
drawing encounters and stuff like that
we were like you know exploring
when between encounters during
encounters all that kind of stuff we
were pissing about
if we weren't [ __ ] you know getting
as little phases in as possible it was
like oh okay
swipe like we went we were being like
really [ __ ] casual we were goofing
off we were like [ __ ] making stupid
call outs
and literally you look at that and it's
like literally it was it was casual all
the way through and then we get to the
last boss
uh happy goes oh i need a wee so he
[ __ ] off for a week
uh and then like literally chats are
going like they're just
like they're like you guys are like
joint top i'm like
what and then like oh yeah you guys are
like in the top three right now and i
was like oh
[ __ ] and then i was like get happy back
and then someone said i
need a way i need a way and then so they
go for a wait and then i'm like
what else you know we're just chilling
and then and then here's the funny thing
we get to the chest after killing the
boss and we're pissing about with the
chest for
like 10 minutes what does this do look
look at the spoils look at this they're
going oh this is [ __ ] cool and then
we get out we're at the menu i'm like
ah we should probably go orbit right and
then like yeah that's pretty good at it
and then like
well that's the thing we were just like
you know on day one we literally just
put on double lockers it is a fallen
raid
yeah so we were like we were like lock
resist and put on a risk runner
yep spot so we
literally just stood there and the boss
was hitting us and we were just like
well i can't survive this
and then i'm stood there with ice falls
as well so if i'm getting close to that
because we had two warlocks three
hundred and me
mm-hmm so the warlocks were fine they
were just like rifts
like dodge i was there with my ice falls
and i'm there like
okay i'm tanking all of this anyway but
if i get close to any death it's just
icefall and it's just like so like
literally that like
literally every encounter we did took
like maybe an hour it took us
it took us five hours 53 to get through
it
what about what about eight tracks what
about eight tracks a truck is like
like about an hour as well wow that's
impressive
because that's what i mean we were going
on long p breaks
like not even messing like i don't know
i don't know if it's number one anymore
yeah definitely but like that's that
that's why we've now started this like
clan pinnacle because we're like
[ __ ] we're actually pretty cracked i was
gonna say so
come which queen can you guys be nice to
savathun and let her survive for like
a couple hours give the rest of
everybody a shot
but no it was like one of those where we
were like playing and we were just like
they're like like here's the thing like
bear in mind me and my team had only
played together like
twice before that as well like we played
the night before in a garden of
salvation run just messing about
um and then we played uh
a couple of weeks earlier before beyond
like came out
um where some of us hadn't done petras
like in myself included because i'd
never bothered because i was like
but then obviously i was on my title
chase
and then people were like oh i need to
do one as well and we're like oh when do
you want to do it it's like oh we'll do
it at some point we'll do it at some
point
there's something like months go past
and then literally it's like
three in the morning just random time
and everyone's just like chilling and
we're just like
go to petra's like it's three it's like
yeah and like
right okay i'm coming on now that i'm
[ __ ] we just that you did it and i
was like i did it
i wanna i wanna stop you i wanna stop
you for a second because one thing that
i like that you're saying
and i think it's really cool especially
as a person who likes to raid
i think what's cool about you and you is
the mentality
chill everyone's having fun because i
think
the problem with a lot of raid teams is
they
they're going at each other they're
taking it way too serious the
the infighting happens you know my clan
is guilty of this sometimes you know
what i'm saying
and the problem is like i have to be
that person in the ring like i can't be
alpha cog
i got to be all right guys laughs jokes
all right look at you know say like
because people sometimes
put so much pressure on themselves in
these environments and you just got to
chill and just have fun with it
and laugh and i like that you guys are
doing that and you're doing it so well
that you get to the last
kind of you guys don't even realize that
you know you're you're at such a high
level you guys are still chilling you're
still keeping that mentality so
i think that's mentality is actually
very important
with raise especially mechanic-based
rates you know what i'm saying so i
salute to y'all for that that's pretty
cool i know kaggle want to know this i
just don't know if he was gonna get
there for asking
top three raids in destiny franchise we
can't do that that's right
we don't answer a lot you want me to go
for it
oh yeah i know yeah i know what mine are
i
i know more than my topic we've talked
about this way too much seth you can
listen to this
you can rank them right here first
for me personally king's fault um
uh just because of the epic scale of
what rx is yeah it's not a damage [ __ ]
it's not a damage mel or anything like
that and it takes a while
but the grand scale of what oryx is
the taken king that is that is a yeah
that is a boss
all the way through to that point which
is why i'm so excited for something
because yeah yeah like that's from even
back there
factual savatune's getting mentioned so
like it's it's the long game
that's what i love about it it's this
entire drawn out story that you're
getting [ __ ] you know
oh this boss is this is [ __ ]
terrifying
fear oryx and then you get to oryx and
he's [ __ ]
masculine like that is my favorite story
mission of all time
music too i'm like oh he's cool as [ __ ]
but like you know it's got even more and
then we get to king's fall
and then oryx is this [ __ ] huge thing
and you're like
this and he's just like over you
bomb really like i
love that great great absolutely love it
so king's fault is that my top then
after that
is last wish
there is a reason for this let me hear
this
kingsville as well is something i like
because it is a
boss fight yes
every single boss in king's fall is a
huge
skulking monster yes that you can
[ __ ] take on it is terrifying it is
big
it is it is it is the stop
it is the stuff of nightmares oh yeah
these are bosses
facts and the more bosses for me the
better
because i am someone with the background
of the likes of doom and resident yeah
just like you he's going to love what he
is this podcast that's why he loves you
so much last wish let me hear wow this
is one of my favorites
not so much with cali and shirochi yeah
sure they're cool but you know they're
just little
floaty [ __ ] awakening skirts um
they're still boss fights they've still
got interesting mechanics they're still
something that you can melt yes right
correct
then you get morgeth who is you know
you perfect that you're [ __ ] slashing
away an ogre or you're using the shotty
and you're [ __ ] right up in its face
i can't stand doing morgan with snipers
that is that is a it's a wrap a pussy's
way out as we'd like to say
people are like oh i'm gonna say the
back with whisper i'm like
come on gotta get in the mix yeah that's
not good
anymore let's go like like i remember
the yi glitch being a thing do you
remember that
with the finisher glitch with the
finishes uh i saw it i soloed morgoth
with that
just off the edge
um and then
what's it called so you got that and
then you've got
vault which is you know it's not a boss
but it's a [ __ ] cool encounter
you've got these big knights that you
can take on so that's pretty sick
but then you've got riven which is
potentially the best
phosphate in destiny history like
yeah i i i still to this day i've only
cheesed ribbon twice
but that's only twice normal
every single time it is ah
it is at least get to where you're doing
the the drop down you know when you when
you're dropping down shooting the boils
i will at least do that bit or up to
there legit
um that is where we go because anything
after that as long as i've done a full
cycle of
room room eyes room room eyes and
cleanse
pop one do damage drop down shoot the
things go back to your normal rooms
if if if she is not at the you know
the ascendant realm bit there right then
just put a sword on
killer because it's like you've done you
know you've experienced
that part which is the encounter and
that is the best encounter in the game
like but hands down that to me is better
than oryx
like wow wow break that that's that's
the first thing so so here's the thing
if oryx
was like that and you could damage oryx
as well as doing the ogre
because you like the interaction with
something or as big a boss on that scale
like the fact that you've always thought
it makes you huge
and country because you're making some
good points this is a good argument i've
never heard anyone
challenge oryx this way the thing to me
which sets it apart is not only do you
have that
right when you're fighting this mythical
thing then you got the queen's walk
outside when you're taking the heart out
that is what i like in the music
i remember what the music you know how i
feel yeah shout out to sky shout out to
the team we have a bungie on
um here's the thing like i'd never seen
a raid where you know you beat it and it
was a fake out like
it's not over and i'm watching people
stream and then they have to carry this
thing out
and it was so well done and if you
remember someone from the community took
a screenshot
and they showed the hands of the
guardian on
the side yeah of the inside
yeah from inside the yeah that was yeah
and you look up at the sky and it's got
the hands i remember
i think i think it was like i can't
remember when my first clear was
but i remember because i was i was still
a casual like pretty well not casual but
like kind of in between casual and
hardcore
up until like shadow keep came out and
then once shutter key came out i started
you know i jumped on pc i started
experimenting more
and then now i'm full time and i you
know could go as [ __ ] hard as the one
yeah but in terms of
queen's walk i remember literally seeing
those hands and was just
like damn that is [ __ ]
terrifying but also cool as [ __ ]
that was amazing well like literally
eve and this is the thing right in terms
of the
eyes of riven yes that is the coolest
boss and like mechanic i've ever seen in
any video game
ever very cool that is [ __ ] cool as
[ __ ]
gold standard stuff but
if oryx had an actual damage phase
in between you know the the pop and the
the things
um the the light erogus would him yep if
when you damage oryx
to stun him if that was an actual damage
phase
that encounter would be perfect i'll get
you like
one million percent that would make oryx
the top boss fight
the only reason riven is up there
literally like this
is because that you can do that to riven
and that to me makes it up there
but the only thing is oryx the only
reason king's fall is so much higher is
because of the
the ramp up story wise and the fact that
it is bigger bosses and
the dreadnought is uh to me personally a
superior location
but that is a little bit bigger but i
like that it's a good argument
i like this is good you're talking about
masterpieces right now so i i just love
this type of talk
this is what i like to talk about like
but again it's one of those where it's
hive and hive over this and uh the
um they're taken what's the the dreaming
city
to me like anything hive related and
it's all [ __ ] shriveled and
uh you know you know what's on the road
what's three number three is actually
there is two
i got people cheating number three and
four for me
are interchangeable what is it today
[Laughter]
there is a reason these two are neck and
neck and that is
wrath i know she's gonna say wrath i
knew she was gonna say that and deep
stone
oh yeah you know what's funny we gotta
start talking deep stuff i haven't
really processed those two feel
like the same raid when you're running
through it the only difference is the
last if
if tannics was at night
instead of daytime that encounter
would feel so much more big than it is
um
like imagine imagine like everything's
black except the flames and then you see
in the flicker of tannics is like you
know
him floating around the electrics in the
dark that would look so much cooler
yeah but that's that's something else i
actually had an idea for what would be
better
for a boss fight with that and how to
introduce tanex back but i will i'll
tell you that as we get on
with this um but you look at it right
you've got aatrax which is a similar
encounter to vosik
yep you've got these things that you've
got these
like different you know the doors that
you've got to go
into to do the mechanic for the
encounter
these rooms at the side that you've got
to do and then you've got to do damage
using you know you've got to take the
shield down or you've got to
detect which one it is that you've got
to go to and then do the damage to that
then you've got to retreat to the room
right and then you go and do it again
the way we do it
which is the which is the six four strap
for eight tracks
which is everyone goes upstairs all six
people do damage to one
and then while the operator cleanses
themself using ricochet rounds the other
four people go back down the lift they
do damage to one
and then they can come back up the lift
and then it's final stand it's final
step
it's literally damage lift damage lift
and then final stand like instantly
it is amazing interesting
but like so that so vosik and
aatrax very similar encounters
you've got then um
the phase ones which are learning the
mechanics for
the last encounter which is including
the last boss as well which is you know
you've got wrath which is learning it
but you're not actually damaging the
boss you're just using the balls to
get it ready you're learning the nukes
on crypt
and then you're learning suppressor on
[ __ ] yeah it is the same
thing yeah and then you get to the last
one
and you're doing the damage plus the
mechanics from the encounter before and
those two raids
are spot on the loot is incredible
the load is incredible yes and they're
both falling around okay so one of these
may tip the scale you've got the steam
engine
and you've got the spacewalk iconic in
their
own right spacewalk right okay so siege
engine
is way more engaging right
and is to me personally
a superior encounter counter yeah yeah
i would give you that in terms of an
experience
oh yeah space yeah d d stone creek push
being
that the space walk must be in a
different place when i hear that
lullabies
oh i could just like sit out there and
then you literally go
out there and you just look down you
looked into the emptiness of space
not even seeing europa at the side not
even seeing the rest of the space
station if you look directly down
and just look like that that there is no
feeling like that and then you've got a
deep stone lullaby and they've got in
the background
and they muffle all of your sounds like
everything is kind of dead you know
what's great
is cranked up more i love right so when
when i do it on
a hunter using
shatterline to skip the entire
jumping puzzle is the greatest thing
ever like literally
you know you know when you open the door
and come out yeah jump over to the ledge
to your left and do a chat line across
you skip the entire jump and puzzle
wow just time your jumps right because
what you do is you know the bit where
the little chest is
yeah what you do is you go from that
platform you shut a line all the way
across to the chest pick that up and
then shot a line all the way through
this is hilarious it's hilarious uh
that's going to shorten it up just a
little bit you got to enjoy the
encounter here you got to enjoy the on
bouncing you're like
done let me ask you this we never we
didn't i don't i know we haven't
mentioned it um
just curious where garden falls for you
very bottom i've already tell me why
tell me why
because you cannot one phase the final
boss
i'm not even messing that is the reason
why that's the reason why i hate that
raid so much
you physically no matter how hard you
try i have not seen anyone since the
izzy nerf that has been able to
face that final boss yeah
that may be an issue with the whole easy
nerf itself
or just it's just because he got nerfed
because of that because yeah
that was it but but you but you look at
it and it's like well if you can't one
phrase the boss no matter how
coordinated no matter how skilled you
are anything like that
if you cannot one phase a boss that
any reason other than the game doesn't
want you to
then then i'm sorry but you can get
[ __ ] like
it's not worth my time like why would i
yeah why would i do that when i can go
and do a legit riven and have way more
fun
the only thing that happens when i go
into a garden of salvation run
is we're in orbit i click uh garden of
salvation
and i'm already the moment i click ready
or launch i am sat there going i want
this to be over already
how good my team is no matter how good
my team is
no matter who it is whatsoever it could
be the most entertaining team i've ever
played with
but the fact that i'm doing a garden my
mood just dips because
it is a garden that's not like me with
spider stars
no see spyro is actually up there in one
of my favorites i can't stand player
there's a right so um
spire and crown are in a very similar
situation same with um
same with era worlds which it it is
the raids themselves for the first half
of the raid well everything before the
final boss
on those three raids is
right you cannot speed them up
it is the same aspire though like all
three of their raids have the exact
same layout it is starting with
an encounter of some sort then it is an
extremely long
tedious jumping puzzle but the first
thing is always time-based it's never
you know it's there's no way to speed
them up then it then it's the jumping
puzzle that's really tedious
and then it's a mechanic-based encounter
again
but it's it's it's one that's like kind
of the last boss but because it doesn't
have a last boss it's kind of [ __ ]
but yeah it's all the it's all the long
basement apartments that just are not as
good
like like like the the the to be fair
fate the the third part of crown isn't
that bad
right that's that's pretty fun to do
especially if you've got anarchy and
swords on
like that's that's pretty fun to do
but all the rest are just kind of like
you sat there and
you're playing it and you're just like i
just want to win the final boss
what about argos though and eater
because a lot i know a lot of people
really like that encounter i really like
argos
don't like everything before it yeah
gotcha so you're like can i just give
this the bottle
run yeah those are those that's the
thing i load into them raising them like
can i just do the boss run but that's
the thing with garden i get into garden
and
i'm not looking forward to a boss
because the boss is a [ __ ] garbo
like she can't get a photo for stuff
not a fan of guardians okay so we gotta
go there's two other we gotta go
[ __ ] well that i will agree yeah the
loot's not exciting at all because you
can get the same stuff
outside of divinity divinity is the only
divinity is awesome
divinity is awesome but it is a tool
it's not a weapon
right but it's a unique tool it's unique
to that i like that they
introduce for support characters that to
help somebody what you're saying i was
gonna say
okay so two ones between both of us
vog and crotis and where do they fall
for you oh that's right
uh right okay so if we're going to
say that's my three and four would be um
what's it called they weren't encrypt
yeah then five
is vog i just
i just love fog and the fact that you
can melt the bosses
i recently went on and i've built a
divorce that's the thing
if your team is coordinated enough to
melt a boss or she is riding or die from
this melting yeah
if your brain got melted she is not
about you
like i love that aspect about you like
you are about melting that boy
probably pisses you off more than
anything that's right oh yeah hollard
last skip
every single time hallowed corrupted is
all right if you can nuke him but if
you're off by a fraction
then that boss fight as soon as as soon
as you as soon as she [ __ ] off because
you haven't one-shot her
then i'm just like okay orbit
the entire thing that i have been
leading up to that entire run is looking
forward to one shot in the boss and if
that doesn't happen then my
my my run is ruined and i cannot be
bothered at that point my interest is
completely out the window
millimeter gone yeah that's literally it
and then it's the same with um exodus
oh exodus crash okay yeah it's like all
those little phases all those bosses
that i cannot one shot
i'm just like okay i'm not i'm not doing
it [ __ ] it
yeah straight glassway's the only
glassware is the only exception because
you can literally just like literally
boss shows up bank
it's it's gone they like they may have
phases but those phases last less than a
second
like if you if you're ready for it it
just literally shows up
mind appears mind left it's like
yeah player one has entered the game
player one has left the game yeah that's
literally how it is
like there were so many times like
literally on stream where it's just been
like
uh whatever mind has showed up whatever
man just showed up and like literally
made it like three two one right bump
and then like literally if finishes it
spawn animation and then it just
instantly goes blue and leaves and then
it's just like and it's left
and it's like sick
because vogue is in fifth uh because
again
boss slogs it is literally
going you've got you know it's a cool
ass thing
yeah sure the gate is kind of a little
tedious but you know it's an
introduction
it's it's getting into the raid yeah
yeah yeah like it's free
whatever like what else um and i don't
know i don't care what anyone says going
for the chest way inside there
instead of going the normal way so
jumping off the edge and going around
that is the superior way if you don't go
that way
but then then you get to you know
oracles and all that oracle's is pretty
cool
but oracle's is kind of you know you're
sat there and you're like i just want to
be on templar
you just need a boss rush she just need
a boss
that is it like literally as soon as we
get to templar
then my interest is peaked because i'm
there like
yes yes let's kill it boss
kiss let's go jump rooms bus yeah
but then like literally so you finish
articles and then that's it and that
looks like
it's like literally put on a sniper
put on galley let's go
let's [ __ ] go i don't know i know
sleeper is better
oh what it is a galley
like literally just jump in and out of
your bubble like something
beat in the middle split up blow
yourself up with the bubble
and then one person doing the thing but
yes and then that then you get to eight
well the gorgons which is you know it's
iconic
yeah um then there's that little thing
that you can you know you can
get superman across um and then it's
atheon who is
[ __ ] awesome the past the present the
future
yeah those audio environments are
[ __ ] cool
everyone is involved especially on
challenge mode
challenge mode for atheon is [ __ ]
incredible don't care what anyone says
um and the fact that you can just
literally go right okay
first three people get teleported in and
right okay they've got one they come out
and the other two people come in
everyone goes in everyone comes out
damage bomb
perfect i love the the splitting up and
they're coming together i love that and
i like the whole
thing like get the oracles so you get
like you're blinded and you have to work
to
clear your site i cleanse your site i
love that aspect i think it's very
underrated
yeah so that obviously will be coming
back this year
yeah and i kind of mentioned it's going
to get a bit of a
not a complete rework but a facelift so
i was curious what you guys think
are going to come in and how many
thydras do you think are going to be in
there
okay um i'm going to let youtube talk
about this because
i actually know
how exactly what's in your age yeah
that's right
i know exactly what's in it because i've
spoken
to you so i cannot hold yes
no but i was like this is baby this has
been his
if you ask him what does this operate
number one is vog so
if they're going to alter your
number one how are you okay with them
changing it up
and then we can read her expressions as
you go through
here's the thing and shout out to the
article i know they've been a lot of
transparent
they'd be very transparent leave a
polygon by the way while you've got to
talk about your thoughts on vlog
i got [ __ ] to do oh okay oh okay cool
yes get the setups going
oh somebody redeemed him who redeemed
her
yeah so this is she's like what is
happening she said yo
katie cat's face is like you are her
last right so right now here at the last
word they we see our
outstanding redeemed some sort of
redeemed reduce got the sit-ups
so we are all about fitness and right
now the sit-ups are in
we have to get right you know saying
this is a covet era everyone's in the
house they can't go to the gym
so my man he has to go out here and
provide inspiration
so this is what's happening at the last
word it's about fitness about staying
you know staying healthy
i knew that that's all this is
she said round two black wig says round
two let's go oh there kayla so you got
the setup she's got the perfect form
going so this is what we do here in the
last one but as far as
the raid is concerned with a vaulted
glass it's like this
my thing is i need
the way we're currently constructed we
are just too overpowered
with current subclasses
with current builds charged with light
you know you name i mean let's be real
when we went back to vault
during age of triumph absolutely um
and i remember going in with the taken
king subclasses
in duval we were destroying like
vault did not stay today when you put a
well in there you put you know stove
tray you put
all these things tether all these things
so i think at the end
end of the end of the day they're gonna
have to introduce something
to the mechanics so my feeling is it's
probably gonna be
unfortunately gonna like it but my gut
says you be quiet
i'm gonna speak to you my gut says that
it's going to be
they gotta have put champions in there
right they're gonna have to put your
ammunition they're gonna have to put
some things to
to to to to slow us down
some things may have to be altered i
don't know how they're going to do the
uh what is the gorgon maze i got to see
how that's going to be handled
i mean atheon for the most part i think
should stay
much the same maybe again just some more
challenging energy enemies
you know again having a wall having a
well having a bubble on those spots
are gonna make things easier so they're
gonna have to introduce some mechanics
and enemies
to kind of get us off our square and get
us doing a couple of different things
so i think the spirit of it is going to
remain the same
for the most part but my gut tells me
yeah they cannot bring this thing back
carbon copy we will melt through that
thing
so fast just with subclasses alone
unstoppable
verse if they break vex wyvers in do you
think they're going to be
unstoppable overload i wouldn't picture
the barrier
i don't think that wyverns will be
champions
okay okay she doesn't think that and you
know what i tend to agree that she
doesn't think
so we gonna move on not get her in
trouble personally
i do not think wyverns are
something that would be like the way
that their skill sets
are i would not put a wyvern
as a champion because i agree it would
be like there are enough as a nuisance
as it is
like there's a lot of people that don't
understand that if you just shoot one of
the siders as they're jumping out yet
like
they just dismantle or they get stunned
there's loads of people that don't know
that if it comes next to and you melee
it stuns it like mid animation and it
just drops to the floor in animation you
can just fire at it while it's on the
floor
like that a lot of people don't know
these things they're like
pretty pretty basic stuff that's like
it's jumping at you don't run away just
shoot at it and it will
it'll be like oh [ __ ] if it gets to you
you punch it and it stays locked up
right like yeah it's what it is it's the
newness of the enemy people
people are just scared they didn't know
what to do yeah i think that's all it is
once you get comfortable you start
experimenting and all that stuff i am
going to try and
say it as
as loosely as possible uh
be careful i'm trying to i'm trying to
be real careful here
it is one of those where
let me just double check this article a
sec just to make sure what i can
cover yeah don't judge you honestly
don't even trust me
let us jump though we don't want you
throwing in the bushes from
no no no i i think i should
be okay with what i'm reading here
but i was gonna say for you cog though
somebody was joking like oh it's
it's okay it's joe who's talking about
it
yeah that article okay okay yes okay
yeah
no i i didn't read it because i was like
kind of like
loosely right okay let me just make sure
that he doesn't
bring up what i think he's bringing yes
you do you do that
so yeah why are we saying they're like
you know um
like encounters like templar and stuff
you could just anarchy a doorway and
right
that's it um okay oh he does talk about
it
okay okay okay oh it's fair game okay
perfect okay so pretty much everything
i'm like okay i can't really talk about
they they've pretty much already said
that so
that takes a lot of the ease off
um okay that's awesome i just can't talk
about
everything else but like so so so
reading that he has already mentioned
that it's pretty much going to be
the same raid it's just going to be
little things there's going to be
champions here and there
right um there's going to be the likes
of wyvern showing up but
overall mechanics will be the same it's
just going to be different enemies than
what you're
used to obviously you're going to have
oracles um
and you've got the likes of you know
fatebringer
that's so key to weapons yeah
i don't know about armor i don't know
about armor
um but as far as i'm let me let me just
double check
can it be age of triumph vex armor
because then i'm down
okay he does he does say the original
vaping okay that's good that's good
right okay so like
it's gonna be well i don't know what
slot it's gonna be
but like it's like seeing the
introduction of [ __ ]
like [ __ ] um firefly fake bringer is
gonna be
insane um all i know
is that um
what's the [ __ ] shot his name oh
yeah nice so found verdict won't have
uh what is it what's the name of the
final round
right right oh yeah that's a thing or
was
was it i think that's the name of it
won't have that because
again it's one of those perks that they
never really liked
um because it was one of those stupid
perks that makes it insane
uh and especially when you've got the
likes of you know um
yeah like one two punch and trench
barrel
and vorpal weapon and all that kind of
stuff that become an issue
having stuff like that uh
instantly becomes an issue in terms of
the grand
like weapon pool so they will have to do
like
some perk tweaking to try and get close
like some people like is fake bringer
gonna be like an arc dragon
theoretically yeah and so in terms of
like
weapons returning and stuff like that
they're not going to do
all of the weapons and this and this
applies to any raids
um
it's more like a pool of like the
favorites because it's like this is like
kind of
throwback to what the best
of what people the manifoldic stuff is
i don't get that i get that i will get
you trouble um yeah
my whole thing is you know i think it's
also again this is coming from a
standpoint we just complained about
the loophole how things are and to me
this is a good way to reinsurge
you know reinvigorate that by having
these weapons and stuff like that
come back and um yeah like there's some
that are just completely iconic that are
going to really
hit the base i'm curious to see like um
what like round for a minute like fate
ring would be like you know
i'm just curious or like certain
right there's one for things uh do you
remember back in the day where vog
had um sorry i'm just hoping to sneak um
back in the day uh obviously you had a
hard mode which had fatebringer in yes
and you had easy mode which had
you know other stuff yeah
we don't have a hard mode as it
currently stands
[Music]
oh okay so there we go
that that may be a thing so maybe
interesting to see how that's
implemented if that's actually a thing
yeah it was it was spoken about
uh obviously it was something that you
know we gave our suggestions
in terms of what it is
we would like to see it implement
because obviously the
the main worry is would it just be the
same as the virus and
prestige would it just be the same as
spyro stars prestige
would it just be like these and that is
not what we want
it is evidently clear that's not what
also the community or anything like that
one
um but my main worry right
this is my main worry because even after
all these these type of things and they
hear our feedback
of like you know we don't want this we
would rather have it like this
we don't want to have and i'm gonna i'm
gonna quote this
we don't want to have everything in the
one mode
and if you want to bring something like
contest as a permanent thing
then what would what would you do spoils
right you would do stuff like separate
the
uh the loopholes so for example having
one weapon
different and just a different coloured
armor set
for a prestige mode does not make it
worth it especially when the thing is
restricting your loadout
that is something that is not fun that
is something the community doesn't like
but the exact but you taking d1's raids
and looking at the difference between
easy and hard mode of the d1 raids is
the perfect example of changing
a mechanic just a little bit the same
with leviathan
leviathan's prestige mode is [ __ ] top
tier
but the prestige mode of the [ __ ]
raid layers
yeah are shite um
like that's the thing leviathan's hard
easy to prestige mode is
[ __ ] it it feels like a d1 did like
alteration
in terms of how the difficulty has
changed and
literally what i would like to see is
see
the easy mode have two three weapons in
with the armor set and then why would
like the hard
slash the um challenge
or contest version of the raid what i
would like to see in that
is potentially double spoils or
another or another three weapons or
something like that that are
completely separate that you cannot get
in normal
right no along with ornaments so you can
use
easy mode to farm the roles for your
stuff
but then you can go into hard mode get
the ornaments
and get the exotic and get spoils
that is how i would split the easy to
hard mode so you want to get the likes
of fan verdict you go and do the easy
one you farm for the shotgun
if you want a fake bringer um and you
want
you know a a universal ornament that you
can use on literally
any set yeah the hard mode
that is how i personally would do it
um well i mean the main the main concern
is
if vog doesn't have a hard mode when it
comes back
then how what's the longevity
and the lifespan of vault returning
well i mean your king's fall sitting at
the top of your list makes perfect sense
because king's fall was built with hard
first and then they plucked little
mechanics out of each encounter to make
normal mode more manageable and then
that's the exact same thing as you're
saying for hard to be
hard needs to be rewarding same reason
you like you got conqueror so you have
the title once
but there's no real ever reason to go do
grand masters they are not fun they're
not rewarding
there's not much benefit to doing way
too much time consuming like the only
reason i do grandmasters now is so that
i can set up for ascendant shards for
seasons to come
like i have i bet right so my postmaster
and my players inventory still has
10 ascendant shards on all three
characters
i still have 50 enhancement prisms on
all three characters post masters and of
my character
you have 40 golf balls in 200 prisms
yeah damn but here's the thing i also
set up
my vault uh i've burnt through most of
these now but i had aeon swift
in my vault all master worked i had like
maybe
20 of them in my mouth all masterwork
ready for if i use
any of my shards or any of my prisms i
can just dismantle one and it just
refills my [ __ ] invent
so like that is the only reason i would
do a grandmaster so that i could
just farm them [ __ ] masterwork
and my eon swifts again and just fill my
vault back up for seasons to come
that's literally the only reason for me
to do a grand master anymore
yeah it's just not worth it to me like
i'm being the same thing but it's like
you know and also just to clarify to
what yeah he said no there is not a
world's first race because it has
technically already been erased yeah
that's why
i've got it yeah it was like people
would be like hey here's a few new cool
things but people are going to finish
that thing in like an hour yeah
the encounters yeah no it it is it like
literally as as you said earlier it's a
it's a it's a reissue
it's not it's basically a remaster of
the raid with a couple of
sprinkles of new things to not make it
exactly the same but it's going to have
the same feeling
so in terms of a in terms of the vlog
there's not a world threat yes sure they
will say congrats but it's not going to
be like you know here's a [ __ ] belt
and all this
exactly yeah because you think about it
there's people that speed run vogue now
still
the people that do that are pretty much
going to do the exact same thing when it
reek when it comes back out because it's
pretty much the same braid
and that is fine that is what we want to
do we want to go back to the vault
we want to [ __ ] shred through it and
we want to have a good time doing it
the key and get some [ __ ] sick ass
along the way
exactly the key for me is going to be
also
narratively how they introduce it um
that's the point and venus doesn't exist
no i know
and the current dcv so the question will
be yeah
does is it will be cool like is it
around like a dcv like a venus
uh season is you know is something going
on is it just a timepiece is it
something where osiris goes back and we
have to fix something
like i want to know how they introduce
it
you know what i would love you know what
i would love right
this would be the coolest [ __ ] thing
ever
this will actually bleed into my um the
tannics idea because i
th this isn't the same thing but like
you know i was saying i had a different
idea for how to reintroduce tannic
straight
um so this is this is gonna go off on a
tangent at some point
but what would be [ __ ] awesome for
vogue right
is just skip the gate bit at the
beginning
right no honestly that's how you get rid
of venus you you don't have the gate
that's how that's how you get rid of
venus but there is a second reason for
that
because what you could do right do you
remember the curse of osiris trailer
oh yes he was in there i was i you
already i'm with you girl
that's how i was thinking i was like oh
you could go outside
and you see the fire team freeze
and to introduce osiris he's ghostless
now
this would be something cool for him to
do he opens a portal
you go back in time you go into vog you
see a
frozen fire team of guardians as you're
doing the encounter
you could see guardians that have been
lost within the vault
frozen in the templar encounters
you could see remnants of previous
guardians stuff
like that would make it cool as [ __ ] and
osiris could be like
i went here with sagira when i
discovered this
so i know how to get in there we can go
there now they open it
up you go in and you start straight away
at the oracle encounter with frozen
stuff all around the place you trigger
the encounter all the minotaurs start
shifting and [ __ ] like that and then it
becomes a basically like a horror game
because all of a sudden everything
that's frozen around you and still
then all of a sudden everything's
activated you'd have to wait for spawn
gates then
because everything's there you just have
to position your team so you don't get
one shot by everything because all the
enemies are already
in the arena that is then a horror game
and a arena survival fight there will be
fire
i i i i don't know if that's gonna be
the perfect way to play
i don't i doubt they go to that level of
detail because this is
we love budgie but uh sometimes yeah
this is this is
so much narrative awesome what you're
saying everything
is like narrative awesomeness right
and i just i the way bungie tends to
operate for boxer is
is they'll do like the first part of
what she said right
we're gonna go out and then we're gonna
go in
and then they like all right you know
they won't they won't
finish it off narratively in a cool way
like how you said it
because that's awesome i i completely i
do agree
the best way to do it introduce it is
onsite like he is literally
tied to vex he's literally tight like
the curse was however
started that way right when you that
that's how we first saw him for the
first time was that
so um yeah like i said they got cool
ways to do this
it's gonna be interesting to see he
definitely i totally forgot about osiris
he makes the most sense
easily just as a way to especially with
segura being gone now so he can't
physically go there himself
so he sends us there to do it he's also
got icora there so if
even though he's lightless he knows how
to do it so he can get icora and her
goes
which brings like cora back into the
[ __ ] story instead of standing there
like a [ __ ]
wet wipe in the [ __ ] summer breeze
dude
like what is she gonna do something yeah
disrespecting the girl but um yeah no
i'm with you
kitty cat on fire as usual um yeah
this is this is what it is there's so
much
narrative opportunity for this to really
do it right and i know i'm outside
something you're satisfied but
it makes perfect sense like and then
here's the other thing
why is he in the tower all of a sudden
you know what i'm saying
he's they're setting him up to be of
like a
regular vendor type character or
whatever they're setting him up for some
he's got a space right here he's
literally out there
now lightless right well he he was
lightless anyway and he's sending these
messages to
zavala in his office that was [ __ ]
cool [ __ ] by the way
um seeing voice notes from osiris
showing off into paula's office in the
tower you're hearing them coming through
you hear about sagira
and then he shows up also for [ __ ]
sake why i didn't take care of a
cutscene
yeah we've gone we've all done that
i've gone in on it and i i've i'm very
not happy with that
which led to my non-happiness initially
when i saw what happened to him
but now that i've read the law that's
outside of the game
where it should have been a cinema like
respect the character but
let me tell you what kitty cat we know
this has nothing to do with the lore
this is bungie and voice actresses and
voice actors and availability
you get nolan to do it that's what they
do with everything they do
right let them disagree nolan norris and
lance eric they just voice the whole
game
like that's all it is you know i said
but yeah i agree i i
i come i will die on my grave even
though i i don't have any inside
knowledge
i have no inside baseball with bungie's
dealings that
that voice actress they could not
because they think about bungie they
want you to come in
a lot to edit your lies they want to
tweak they want to do this
and some people are they're availability
like dinklage when
they had diglitch for dinklebot he was
in the height of game of thrones
tyrion was like a the the most popular
thing
and like for him to come back to this
you know little video game and it
probably is mine
you know he's got his schedule just so
busy so i think it just comes down to
sometimes they pick two popular voice
actors and
voice actors that have these very busy
schedules you know what they should do
right even though yes they are
big voices and all this kind of stuff
and they have their schedules and
they're starting the other
they have a huge community that would be
more than [ __ ] happy to voice act for
the game oh yeah
yeah that's that's a fact i don't know
look at the likes of blessings
you can't voice someone fine get someone
from the game
i know get someone who plays the game
and they would be more than happy to
probably dedicate a couple of
pictures that'd be [ __ ] awesome
imagine imagine literally like you're
there and you're like oh we've got this
new character coming in
um we know it's not going to be a big
thing but you've got this character that
shows up there's this one time
and it's like okay cool and this is the
three here's the voice lines
if you want to do it and if it works
then we will invite you back for the
next expansion when they get more
expansive dialogue
but you literally send that to a couple
of people around the community see what
people can do and then see what people
produce and then it's like okay well
there's the character there's someone
from the community that people recognize
like why the [ __ ] does shohan not have
asked across his voice i don't [ __ ]
know it
this is like [ __ ] hello again lady
[ __ ] fellas and ladies
gonna get nasty like all that kind of
stuff like that would have been
[ __ ] incredible yeah i mean that is
true i mean
they they listen there's there's no
shortage of research in talent
in our community in the bungie the
destiny community we've got
complete talent that we can use now in
their defense
you know they've used guys before and
gals before
as far as um you know gameplay design
stuff so they they've made some strange
strides as far as contractual stuff
i just think whoever's in charge this is
my gut whoever's in charge
of that stuff right comes from
a very like like even like i said we had
sky on from um
you know the the music director team and
all that
they're very orchestra they're very
grandiose in everything they do
right when you when you break your new
ip you got marty o'donnell to do your
music
like like this is i mean their music is
orchestra like
it's it's really you know grandiose and
i think
it's that mentality whatever they still
they're still keeping that and i'm not
mad at that because let's be real a lot
of it
is high quality like these we got lance
reddick and zavala you could say we
won't as well like it's amazing
you know what i would love right you
know i would love as an
antagonist to zavala to be um the guy
that plays captain holt from brooklyn
nine-nine and have those two have a
[ __ ] like an argument that'll be done
that would be
the greatest thing i have ever heard in
my life
and and oh spiro realized like the guy
does osiris which i remember
omar all day like he's like been in the
mummy he's got
all these iconic cat and then like
horror iconic like
no no like these even kay like cocaine
was what's his face
nathan like these are iconic
actors and actresses so that i think
again part of me loves that they shoot
for the stars and they they get the best
talent
but then there's a part of me that's
like okay maybe you need to scale down
you don't have to go super a s t or
actor all the time
and get someone in that can actually
consistently
do the changes and the edits that you
want all the time
guys shout out let me tell you people i
got a shot i don't know who they are but
who does the
uh but we gotta shout out save 14
whoever they chose for that i don't know
who the actor
he's amazing yes yeah he's amazing he's
pretty great i like i go to go dexter's
safeway just listen
i gotta say crow this season crows great
but yo we gotta give drifter some love
uh
yeah he did a great one like no one can
do everything but um yeah whoever does
the drift they're like
all right all right all right like he's
just a sheisty character like everything
about him
did you hear about how that happened no
tell me
they originally were going to get
drifter to actually do the
the ghost comms
over the comms they couldn't get him
scheduled to meet up with theirs to get
it done
so then they had um
nolan to to try like because he was like
oh i'll just [ __ ] do it and like
did the impression and they said holy
[ __ ] that's
cool but then they were like they were
like do it more ghost-like because
yeah that sounds too good no one would
know because
literally he literally sounded exactly
like drifters
like ghostify that and then
that's the thing it's like if nathan if
[ __ ] nolan sorry can do all of these
things you can do kade without
most people realizing yeah he can do
drifters
why not just get him to do the whole
thing
what it is his check is too big that's
what it is they got to slow down over
his check because
they give a llama listen for all the
dinklebot fans i don't know if dizzy's
in here
nolan is the superior you see the
versatility in this man you see what he
could do this is insane like
the fact that they could he could do
cade in the drifter
effortlessly and you wouldn't even know
i didn't even
know at one point until they had to tell
us when cage obviously when nathan
philly went on
i mean that no north was doing it i'm
like yo i could barely hear
any difference like that's insane his
his talent is is amazing he doesn't get
enough credit
he doesn't get enough credit so i know
we've talked about a lot of stuff but we
still have one
giant pandora's box to
and that is the future of our subclasses
i had to talk about it we went deep on
raids which is part of what we've been
going on anyway but
that's been the big drama of the week
and i figured i'd save this wonderful
nugget to the end um
i watched a nice about 30 minute video
from our guest
lots of passion in that video it was um
strong words of choice strong strongest
shirt would you say i went over the top
with that
no i just i think it came from a
passionate place no i would say it was
like
it came from the heart it came from the
heart if you come for that
i could not hold that back like
everything that's like kind of been
piling up and up and up uh in terms of
like frustrations with the game
frustrations with this frustrations with
that
and then especially when you get invited
to you know these
these like events and stuff to give
feedback on the game
and then to like feel like oh they are
listening
and then for luke to
say that was just kind of like
you know what people like like the
picture that you sent me
yeah that's that's what we want
exactly right that is exactly what we
want
yes and that's what we've told them we
want
yeah and all this kind of stuff and yet
oh let's make it not what you want
let's make it what we want and make it
garbage
and so for those who don't know come on
i'll let you i'll let
not everybody has probably read these
articles yet polygons got some
interviews with the bungee guys
and they've been kind of drip feeding
those out in proper bungee fashion
as a plate as everything else yeah
exactly
so the big one that seemed to cause the
biggest hubbub
as to cross made a video our awesome
guest she listened to that one and just
took it to another level
and a lot of people have had issues
because
the idea came up about the light
subclasses and people have had questions
cognito and i and other guests have
wondered what is the future of our
subclasses
because right now you have forks but
very bespoke like you get very no
very little choice of those they
introduced aspects and fragments
with stasis you get a little bit of
customization with the fragments
there's gonna be more aspects introduced
in future seasons as we've been told
so now it sounds like we're gonna get
more aspects
maybe more fragments as well we'll see
when it comes to stasis
but they've also said they potentially
aren't going to be doing much to the
light subclasses
alone for a while that's like not even
it's not there's not like a road map for
those there's not like a planned date
like hey they'll be seasonally they'll
be annually
not a thing at this point but in luke
smith's hypothetical fantasyland as he
called it in the article
he said that the subclasses that we do
have now
some have specific like ip defining
characteristics like nova bomb for
example
so he thought that you know we could
potentially do away with nova warp as
nova bomb
is one of the big ones as soon as he
read that i thought of nim and i saw him
on twitter so
nem plays the edge lord is like the
novel warp master so i was feeling bad
but then you take something like
warlocks for solar you have well of
radiance a very specific purpose
dawn blade could not be farther apart
but they're both solar
and they're like well how do we define
those and i'm sitting there talking to
i don't even know who my discord
somebody
and then you see people i was literally
browsing through reddit all pictures by
the way because just like ever
all the new stuff and i see somebody
come up with a solar warlock
subclass tree that looks like stasis and
the idea is
their thoughts of taking it down to just
one super
is the big hub says this is one super
right now we have one one one
the others have two as readers just said
that
as booty's just said in chat that is
what i've been asking for
since d2 arrives and bubble was a tree
right being able
to hold a super button down and for it
to act in a different way
thank you that is why like i was a
bubble babe in d1 i didn't do anything
other
in d1 than be a weapons of light bubble
titan that was what i did
and in d2 as soon as i seen
that you could do a bubble or do a
sentinel
with the same tree free is
beautiful that is the most alive
feeling super in the game yes the
versatility
yeah it allows you oh [ __ ] you're in a
pickle pop a bubble
oh you've got damage with a bad so your
super is useless
which is the whole point of what they
didn't like in d1 where you would hold a
bubble for an entire encounter because
you don't need to use it because
you know you need offensive supers and
[ __ ] like that and
or it's a mechanic based thing and you
don't need the bubble so you just hold
on to it
same with self-res they didn't use that
because it's there
but if you're in an enemy encounter
right and you don't need bubble
so it's like oh okay what can i do i can
pop bubble and i can
i can pop sentinel sorry and just run
around for a little bit and throw some
shields and [ __ ] or i can slide in front
of my mate put a barricade up one side
and put a
shield up the other side with my super
stuff like that
makes top tree sentinel the most
superior
[ __ ] tree in the entire game to
anything
and i'm sorry to people that disagree
with that
that is the most [ __ ] awesome thing
ever is a top tree bubble titan
um specifically as
a sentinel and why
in the ever living [ __ ] can they not
do that with everything dawn blade tap
it
you want to go for a well hold it yeah
you want it you want to do
[ __ ] you want to do blade barrage
hold it while you're in
the air specifically uh if you want to
do a golden gun
you tap do it an oval warp [ __ ]
tap if it's an overbomb hold [ __ ]
and then like literally this is my this
is my biggest example that i could give
right
imagine being on a arc warlock i
personally that is my least favorite
subclass
in the entire game on any character
right
literally i that like literally across
all classes all subclasses put into one
pool
arc warlock is my least favorite just
because
it's pretty dope if you could sit
yeah right so if you literally just go
tap and you do storm call or if you go
hold and it charges up as you're holding
it and then you release
and it fires it right stuff like that
while also being able to simultaneously
be able to select having an
arc buddy your ark buddy can shoot the
[ __ ] ads around you
while you're dpsing with a chaos reach
that
is the most perfect thing in destiny
that i would love
the same same goes for again going to
top tree sentinel right instead of
having overshield because i'm using ice
for mantles
why can i not do stuff like pop a bubble
but then have detonation melees so
anything that gets near my bubble i can
literally jump
out punch pop my ice falls my team's in
the thing behind me
i'm over shielded i'm fine and
everything explode around me
that is [ __ ] awesome
and why that is not a thing or being
able to use
[ __ ] um little hammers while also
having throwing hammers or having
sunspots with the [ __ ]
big yeah like
stuff like that would be incredible
having
you know uh what what even is
[ __ ] hunter i don't even know having
you know either the
what disrespectful what you're getting
to is what i was thinking about as well
is
most of the supers almost everyone you
could narrow down to
two two two would be like the perfect
number for everything
and you could do just as thesis is you
go like do you and you
or you can do it your way will you
literally click or hold which is almost
even better because you have the option
in the moment which is the best way to
go as you're saying because
in the moment do i need a bubble hold it
do i need that and that and you could
make just about every super
as you said golden gun or life
to the subclasses it adds more
situational combat
it allows the player to think
how do i want to go about this at this
second
because then you don't have panic supers
either
because you've got the likes of blade
barrage you would have to
hold it to do it you wouldn't be able to
just go click because then you'd have
your [ __ ] golden going out and you
sat there like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
no but like again it's like oh i need a
well i'll hold it like a sponge
or you tap it you get your dawn blade
out and you can race around there is
one of the coolest things i can like i
can think of is imagine right
going back to imagine you're like being
able to charge your super as fast as
possible right
like is it let's let's say in that
luke smith fantasyland that that exists
right
one of the coolest [ __ ] things ever
would be able to go
i'll buy by the same characters bear
this in mind right
the same characters you're in a fire
team of three you have a void hunter
you have a sentinel and you have
a solar warlock right
the [ __ ] most badass thing i could
ever imagine
i think i know you're going with this
but i'm going to let you see oh you know
exactly where i'm going with this
right enemy wave spawns
uh hunter shoots tether warlock pops
well
titan puts the bubble over the well
right
and then immediately as soon as they're
done
warlock jumps out pops dawn blade goes
ham you've got the hunter which is
protecting the bubble
using their [ __ ] uh whatever the
[ __ ] void knives are
and the titan pops the sentinel shield
and starts throwing that out
while the well and the bubble and the
tether are still going on the same fire
team
because the combat is awesome that would
be [ __ ] fine
fantasy that people want it is that's
the thing is like that is what people
want and that sounds i was like i knew
where you were going when you had it all
lined up i was like you got the
recharging supers like you do one and
then you get it recharged you flip to
the other then you have both working
their version and their argument to you
is probably going to be well no it's a
slap but the idea is like
what type of encounter do we have to
build that you won't
nuke because with six supers between
three people for them to build an
encounter
that you have to that is going to be a
challenge what you do
what type of encounter is it going to be
that's going to challenge you
if you can do what you just sold out
yeah that's probably
their counter argument to that that's my
only yeah
the thing right you've gotta you've
gotta look uh like you would never be
able to recharge a super that fast yeah
sure if you're using all three supers at
the exact same time you'll be able to
get half a super with the way that the
current generate
like generation rate is you got thresh
you might be able to get a little bit
closer
stuff like that but and it's a big one
right hopefully it is if
you're able to nuke encounters
without supers anyway where is the harm
in bringing that kind of fun to
encounters and encourage you to use your
supers
i don't use my super most encounters
because i've got sentinel
or i've got bubble and i don't need to
use them i'm sat there like we're
literally doing like
three man raids without using supers
because you don't need them
no like i get that if you're able to do
that with weapons
and like the and if their argument is oh
well what i can't call with designs like
well you're designing those encounters
as it is with only what potentially one
super if not
none going off and it's still easy so
why not just allow us to go [ __ ] god
mode and just absolutely shred through
things because then at least it is
fun i i hear you but they're not doing
that
yeah i i i i love your passion i love
where your heart's at and it's
it is the most fun thing everything you
said
is so fun and the stuff that i love to
do as well
it reminds me of when like you said we
were talking about earlier the
the the dyer uh scholar mama cara cara
yeah we we're just running and then
you've got um
what what the what they've gone uh the
gauntlets for hunter when they do the
blade barrage
you've got orpheus rigs and they're just
tethering all over the place it's just
cool as [ __ ]
was fun it's a power fantasy game to see
and you're sat there holding your shield
up you've got your other titles
shield runs out you swap places with
your teammate and he pulls it out in
hard move menagerie when everyone's
under leveled
[ __ ] like that feels amazing amazing
and it's not because it's making the
encounter easy it because it's
[ __ ] epic to see you've got two
titans like
working behind each other i can imagine
them picture in a movie sense right
i know it's i know she's gonna i know
this i know it's not they would make the
best movie ever but
yeah well not with the [ __ ] nurse
that are going on that wouldn't well but
like literally imagine right
imagine right you've got the teammates
all there they're all shooting and
you've got this titan at the front doing
all that you've got the [ __ ] lights
sparking off them not orbs because it
wouldn't look the greatest well like
imagine like sparks of light like
popping off the super as their [ __ ]
thing
you see the titan behind him literally
back to back giving him fire on a six
yeah and then literally his super runs
out so like they kind of do like a 180
spin
still back to back and then he pops his
super and they're both there just like
kind of like
left to right kind of that'd be awesome
that we envisioned because you know like
when the trailers and all that come out
like you see the destiny 2 trailer come
out and you've got like the titan and he
[ __ ]
throws the shield comes back to him and
he goes punches this one and then jumps
up through the floor [ __ ] like that is
what players want to be able to do
the power fantasy the fans we can't do
that because it's like oh no you guys
are against the darkness the doctors are
apart for you well
news flash bungee we now have the
darkness why are we not overpowered
some would say stasis but yeah
isis trials this weekend
just hate to be the bearer of bad news i
just hate it i just hate it
in chat as well as chats just said in
the law piece where sagira dies
osiris pops all three elements yeah he i
was like i wish we could have seen that
i didn't even know
he could do
it's been in the law before saint for
ian has
used a bubble and then immediately ran
out the bubble using a sunbreaker
yeah be that it would be nice if they
could show it to us right yeah here is
the
here is the coolest [ __ ] thing right
yeah i think you guys have seen me draw
my titan before
imagine right you're there you've got
the [ __ ] sentinel shield in one hand
you've got the hammer sole and the other
and then like literally you throw the
hammer at all you've got to go and pick
it up so what you do is you pop striker
in one hand and then
strike land on the hammer and pick it
back up that would be
so [ __ ] cool yo they
designed
mayhem as a modifier in activities
just to let allow what you have right
now
be like mayhem vault of glass mayhem
nightfall just like have it don't excite
me like that
don't excite me like that like you know
the final mission of red wall
yeah with gold yeah there is
there is a picture which i've got which
is pretty infamous for looking badass
and it is i have popped the bubble and
within the bubble i have popped sentinel
and i've got the shield pop and it's
reflecting off the bubble
you can see gaul in the distance lifting
his [ __ ] thing up
as he's popping his dorm blade and it
looks [ __ ] badass
and i'm like that's what you want to do
you want to be able to
it would be nice if we could flex our
powers every so often
what she gonna get is that that's the
thing we have killed these dogs
or a cinema if we're lucky
that's what did that i hate to be the
bear bad news
i hate to spoil the party i don't daddy
bungee
they are the champions of balance and
knowing what's right for us
and all that is all that you say is just
way too fun
it's just way too fun and they but they
are not about that
that's that's the thing right so here's
the thing yeah balance needs to be a
thing
because you know it's it's it's a game
you can't have it being too broken
but when you think about the most fun
that you've had in destiny
for me personally what i think about is
two four four punch hammers
i think about using paragon graves with
striker
i think about using prometheus lens in
crucible
everything is broken when things
are [ __ ] insane
that is when we have the most fun
because at the end of the day it is a
power fantasy
yes sure you want challenge as well but
why not have
challenge while everything else because
there's a thing we don't mind having
damage gates
when we're overpowered when we're
absolutely [ __ ]
cracked because then you know
why not because then you can literally
just shred through things and especially
if you've got the team coordination to
be able to do so
but i want to iterate
if the game is trying to force you
to not be able to one phase bosses and
stuff like that
but then every time you find something
that is fun like the likes of two four
hammers
and the likes of peregrine grief striker
and the likes of wither horde
being able to do double damage and all
that kind of stuff
and we have killed gods and yet
we're still being pushed down to
basically fight with the equivalent of a
new light but have the knowledge of a
god killing machine
it does not feel as good and it feels
like they're holding us back
it feels like we're going for balance
for the sake of balance
and personally after playing back for
blood and playing that on
easy mode and kind of struggling with it
a little bit
like there's no difference
if i can do a solo legendary lost sector
while flawless
on destiny but then struggle playing
easy mode
on a zombie horde mode i think that kind
of says something especially when you
can go into gambit and get shredded by
bosses faster than raid bosses
yeah game it's weird like
kinda a little weird and i get that is
potentially a balancing issue
but if we're meant to be these [ __ ]
insane guardians that were meant to be
well then why are we [ __ ]
i mean i miss said fred said it in chat
he's like
strikes so many strike modifiers are
gone and it's like strikes are not that
big of a deal especially vanguard
strikes
like yeah you do you do your three if
you want your pinnacle and you're like
why am i going to do those for a week
but if there was a point where it's like
rainbow burn mayhem strikes and you're
just going in there just
fireworks as you go through the entire
thing you lose nothing by doing that
and you can go through and have some fun
like here's the thing where shredding
strikes in like three to five minutes or
less
right especially with a lake when lake
shows up in a couple of runs one after
the other that is the greatest thing by
the way
and you're literally just farming for
vanguard tokens when there's a
vendor refresh but that is another thing
especially when shadow price is coming
back which is by far potentially
in my top three primaries of all time
within destiny 1.
why um i will be farming the living [ __ ]
out of that
and being able to jump into there
potentially do the likes of lake
in two minute runs i can get my weeklies
done in like 10 minutes
like but then like that's supposed to be
a weekly and i want to
i want to emphasize what it says on the
you know within the ui and everything
weekly challenge is to do three strikes
using a burn right
that's not a that's not a challenge
that's a participation model
right and that's what a lot of destiny 2
seems to be
is participation medals and yeah we get
it people want to be able to feel good
about playing the game
but at the same time when you slap
challenge on something you expect it to
be a
challenge exo challenge really
that's that's jumping practice mostly
yeah
and and a little bit of shooting like
[ __ ] out i use double double shotgun
with a [ __ ]
sword in that and it literally doesn't
hinder me whatsoever
i gotta jump it good i i love kid but
you represent
such of the your skill level and what
you guys are able to do
right it's so amazing right but you
represent such a small percentage of the
masses like i'm dealing with
let me give you an example i'm dealing
with people that are now
getting into destiny now because it's on
xbox next gen console 60 frames for the
first time
they sing game pass they playing for the
first time they like cog
i want to play this looks cool i always
see you you posted stuff about destiny
i want to play right we're doing
eremus right the story missions right
they are unable to hang in those
missions whereas people like us we were
already getting to 1200
12 20 we had found the schemes to
to to to go to get the drops from the um
the
loot cave the lost sectors again the
skill
gap you have to understand your skill
gap is so
superior to everyone else so but you
represent
this amount of people right the majority
of the people
unfortunately are those guys so that's
the first part
the second part is i'm with you with the
power fantasy right i love feeling
strong
i love that feeling of of of
going in there with a coordinated team
and
melting something it feels amazing i'm
with you there it feels bad
the problem is how do they balance it
because
here's the here's the flip side if we
keep doing that
then we get everything and then we get
bored
let's be real we get everything
this was my problem with d2 vanilla we
we blazed rule
everybody got the participation trophy
everybody got all the raid weapons
everybody got all the stuff and then
once we did it
what we do we stop playing destiny
that's what we're doing yeah yeah you
know so the reality is
as much as i hate when i fake i fight
aramis and
the captain and as soon as i'm about to
lament and then they stop me
all these are in because they know us
as a player yeah that's true and look i
don't like i think
i think there's a a middle ground they
can have some
this this is my one of my things i
always feel this is where i i'll cut
i'll cut you some slack and feed into
what you're saying
one of the things i have a problem is if
i get to
pass the hard cap or whatever it is 12
50 or whatever right
and now i'm about 1267. i'm close to
1270.
i want to go back into a 1250s
i want to be able to dominate that stuff
because
technically yeah i am above light i'm
with yeah that's where i'm with you
if i and i'll finish i'll give it back
to you guys if i put in the work
to dedicate to this game as a hardcore
player
and i'm going past pinnacle level i'm
doing all these things my light level is
i should be able to come in there and
absolutely dominate some 12
20 12 40 content and help out those guys
who are sherparing
that are low like to get them to where
they need to be and that's the only
balance i feel that they haven't got
right
like stuff still hurts i shouldn't be in
gambit and getting
hurt like like you know i'm the 1260 i'm
a 1270. you said i'm saying like
so that product i'm gonna let y'all go
100 with you there
yeah like 100 and as chat saying that
like the likes of sundial
like you know easily teaches you how it
works
so everyone can get involved um
i mean i guess i guess the reason why
i'm so like
so so so set on the you know
you know because you were saying like
the ones that jump in and they're still
unable to do erroneously and all that
kind of stuff
the the gap is there but like
with personally what i have seen
i have seen like they maybe play the
game for like a week and then after the
week they're already like
like if the skill gap is this and after
a week they're like
up here right like that that's
that's my worry with it really because
there's only so much
that they can do and if after a couple
of weeks they're at the same
level or the same lack of things to do
that are hardcore players at
then that is its own issue in
a separate way right because
if not only the hardcore running out of
[ __ ] but also the casual
is then that is a whole other monster in
its own
thing because the amount of times i've
seen the likes of
um like for example the flaming booty
juicy was in chat earlier i don't know
if he still is
i remember we met him
i think it was around shadow keep he'd
never read it before
anything like that like for [ __ ] sake
i've i've taken a nine-year-old through
every single raid and he's picked it
awesome
and he's nailing it and he's leveling
faster than most people i know because
he's
you know he's looked into how we've done
things and he's like nine-year-olds
at the time yeah well but yeah but like
literally booty juice right who's in
chat now
three weeks in to playing the game for
the first time ever
he'd done all the raids with me and then
a couple of weeks later completed the
game hasn't played it since
and he's he's just jumped into um
he jumped into beyond light like a week
or two ago
um which is obviously three weeks behind
everyone four weeks behind everyone
something like that
and he's already three man in raids with
us
and you look at it from that perspective
and it's like okay so everyone that's
like
you know all these people that i'm
seeing that are like either
they're super duper behind they're rusty
or they've never played before
and then a couple of weeks in they're
able to jump into raids and just three
man them
like that's kind of that's the line why
i'm like
you know kind of is not that high
like you're saying the skill gap is
there like as soon as they jump on yeah
they're at the [ __ ] you know
they're at rock bottom they're [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] and we're all up here
but it does not take them long
i think it's you i think you underrate
how great you are
like i'm watching you you did something
i was watching you like
i love polaris lance i watched you come
up with the most
efficient strategy to get this catalyst
in the ascendant realm you stood on the
thing you shot your head
i'm like i didn't even think about that
like i was like because that
that catalyst is debate of my existence
it's still not completed i've watched
your video
i'm getting it done again but it's like
i just think
that you and your team you guys are so
efficient you guys are so amazing and
that
you could grab anybody off the street
you could grab
dye well i mean now you go now you're
getting into actually
yeah so we taught the nine-year-old
beyond like we actually did all the
raids before we all night came on did
them all back to back with him
um but as yeah he's just pointing out
the other day um
emily have you seen emily emily r yeah
yeah yeah so so she was she was she
doesn't play the game because she
doesn't get time on it
so she was like 11 60 or something like
that and we carried her through
deep stone dude she had no business
beating here
that's how great she she could not
damage enemies in everything one shot
and we managed to get the clear that's
what traffic yeah if you do a three man
you have two extra just like
exactly three warm bodies basically that
are just like
helping well it's one of the it's one of
those like the the ones i'm more
thinking about are the likes of booty
juice and
you know the nine-year-old and all that
like they'll go from like literally
there and all it takes them is you know
like doing
a tiny bit of reason not even that much
research it's just like you know playing
the game and then bumping into
you know someone and then they bump it
and then yeah and then
particularly they bump into
you know someone that knows how the game
works
and then on an x and then it just it
spreads then and then
every part of the game just gets blitzed
and
that that's the thing and i feel like
that's that's potentially you know like
a
content a hardcore kind of issue
because you know we are as you say super
duper efficient we know the game inside
out it's
all this kind of stuff and we do put a
lot of time into it but
at the same time that one over there
yeah
at the same time it is also
you know if if they are wanting people
because they want feedback from the
likes of myself they want their feedback
from the likes of glad they want all
that
and they want to know what it is that we
want no actually
and you know we get the opinions of our
communities
and pass it on we do that on a regular
basis
we always you know being the voice of
people but it's not always our own
voices too
like we listen to our chats and stuff
listen to what it is that they want
and the general consensus of what i've
picked up
is just generally that you know
yeah sure not everyone watches streams
yeah sure not everyone watches youtube
some people just don't get involved in
that kind of stuff
and specifically in
you know that side
yeah sure that than that that's that's
okay
but that is also the blueberries that
will be fine
you know absolutely just you know
they'll be fine walking through it
and i'll be fine but they'll play the
game like once every yeah
a couple of months out and then it's
something they bounce out
but then you've got everyone else who
does get you involved so when you say
the destiny community everyone gets
involved on twitter everyone gets
involved
on youtube everyone gets involved in
charity events everyone gets involved in
this
people know each other it's a community
so as people are bouncing off each other
and looking at content creators learning
these strats learning how people do
things
learning how to be efficient right
then people are getting better and
better and better and better and better
and then it reaches a point where
you know most of the like this world's
first race
there are maybe five teams in the top
20 30 that i've heard of i've never
heard of any of the others
right myself included so many new teams
so many the engagement was off the
charts
and you see and you see that and it's
like right okay that should kind of be a
bit of a red flag that the community has
got a lot better we've had a lot of time
all year to be able to and yeah i know
copenhagen's been a thing obviously
that's a that's a completely
that is something that's not overlooked
right but at the same time
if the general like entire player base
has gotten better to the extent where
you can get
that many clears on day one then
there comes a point when you've got to
go right okay
i've got a respect that the player base
isn't [ __ ]
and respect that maybe
just maybe there should be a little
couple of things
turned up and a little more
i will say as a counter to where you're
going um
as we get more and more skilled no it's
like believe me it's like i fully get it
like
i'm a content creator it's like
cognito's like in the loop of all this
stuff we
most people who are watching a podcast
about destiny
they're pretty in the loop in the know
be like hey what's the efficient donning
strategy
everybody watching this probably knows
everybody who's listening to this
podcast probably knows that stuff
the issue that bungie will get into at
that point is if they keep building
things we get into the reckoning bridge
right is where we get into where they
made it
where you had to have these specific
things and supers and all these things
and that's what that pinnacle built to
it's like we got better gear got better
stuff got harder and then it got to be
the point the only way to cross a bridge
was exactly what you said you guys who
are an optimal team
you can get through it but for
the half of the community that isn't in
the community
the half of the player base that does
play sometimes they see something that's
insurmountable because they don't have
the tools the know-how or the group to
play with but but
to to katie's defense she is making a
good point
from the standpoint of we're at this
point
where people go to these you know that
you know herself the astor crawfs the
cactuses you know i'm saying dados or
whatever right
and they have a resource right to now
improve themselves to get on the level
to conquer the content
here's the problem now that we're not
gonna win this battle with bungie
when they look at those numbers and they
look at this raid versus
look at deep stone [ __ ] versus every
other raid engagement
and they see that many people logging on
right they themselves say oh yes this is
what we want
bring in the money bring in the
engagement new people and and i know
us hardcore we don't like to hear that
honestly right
100 sorry to cut up i 100 agree with
that though
the amount of people that got a day one
clear that was incredible to say
that that is what i want i want people
to participate
to participate right but this is why i
agree with you i'm actually gonna i know
where you're gonna go
i i'm gonna which is
that this is what they got to do now now
that they've got this engagement
right they now have to respect
the one percent the hardcore who now
need those
challenge modes needs those things that
show a level of skill that only you guys
can get
that now whether it's the emblem whether
it's a different and what's
extra ornaments whether it's extra water
whether it's the challenge mode
as a mode itself that you guys can
select to get that difficulty that
actually is going to challenge
you guys that are just blitzing through
the content because it's just
too easy for the super hardcore
and i think that's the problem right now
the problem right now is
they they've kind of not respected the
hardcore
that way they giving you got that's why
like adept weapons are trying to come
back
and all this stuff is coming but what do
you think what do you think and
reference
like what do they need to do for you
for me yeah um
so as i said earlier like in terms of
the the hard mode rate
um something like that but being
rewarding enough for me to do it like
just going oh there's an extra weapon in
the loophole or oh it's the same armor
set in a different color that
is not it that that is not it it
needs to be like you know an extra shot
like for example
right if crypt had a hard mode that
could have a farmable version
of eyes of tomorrow so that you can
actually go for it more than three times
a week
or you get double spoils so you can get
two drops of heritage at the end of a
run instead of just the one
and depending on how fast you like get
these strats down to
you could easily get through stuff like
that especially the hardcore
especially if you're zooming through
raids and stuff like that getting double
drops
or getting an extra chance at the exotic
at the end because it just won't [ __ ]
drop for you anywhere else
yep good point stuff like that would be
where it goes and bungee for [ __ ] sake
55 plus is not high style armor no like
jesus [ __ ]
yeah i agree with you they they
disrespect food so for somebody at your
level this is something i've always
thrown up before and i've wondered
for one the fact that the raid mods
cost like four or five energy oh i just
don't use them oh it just
bugs the hell on me that that's even a
thing like if you have a build you said
you're like i got my like
resilience i got my intellect i got my
specific build i got my loadout for
protective lighting
literally my loadout specifically is
taking charge protective light charged
with light
uh owner charged um which was it was a
high energy fire sorry
yeah and then so i will use them three
and then
i will use global reach nice
and then if i'm using those then the
fifth one
will be either shield break charge
depending on what i'm fighting against
for this season exactly which one i will
use the likes of abyssal charge which is
void melee kills give me charge with
light
so and that is every single armor set
that i use
why i do this is what i don't understand
right
why do the raid mods take up energy to
use
exactly that's what i was getting louder
the people for the back i need i need a
bunch of to hear that
wow they should be they should be
intrinsic or zero
one way or the other they should be
intrinsic on armor
there should be some like that's what
you're talking about you want to be
rewarded for your time
and while the unique perks are cool they
had an article like
well we have unique perks in the loop
pool how long until they get into
seasonal weapons how long until
reconstruction drops on a season 14
sniper rifle
does that bother you if it does i'd say
where
do you say a year i said yeah because
then the weapons get cycled out from the
previous year because sunset and exists
so the next time that the weapons cycle
around
then it's in the general loop pool okay
that's a fair what about you cog on that
one for raid perks
to get into the normal loop pool oh into
the normal loop
yeah like season 14 seasonal shotgun has
reconstruction oh you mean
reconstruction like stuff okay oh yeah
um okay what's your answer she said a
year i i was saying
literally because so for example right
imagine
uh let's say i don't know let's say
sacred provenance is actually good right
and it had some unique perk that like
you know did
did action
i'm still working on my slow slow dinner
and you're trying to make me nuts
so imagine something like that right so
you've got a rate you've got you've got
a rate
that raid is gonna get cycled out at
some point anyway
right right and yeah sure the raid's
gonna be around forever
but at the same time there's gonna be a
certain point where you go okay i don't
need to do the raid example
last wish you don't need to do the raid
but people like doing last wish so they
will run last wish
there's no reason to do it except for
the likes of supremacy but why go for
supremacy
when you've got the new sniper which has
reconstruction and [ __ ] on like
no absolutely but at the same time right
you want to wait for something to sunset
before you bring back something that is
so for example right
now that mountaintop is sunset why the
[ __ ] is micro missile not on multiple
grade launches oh they're not having it
daddy there is an example and then the
likes of wendigo
wendigo wendigo's [ __ ] uh pinnacle
perk was [ __ ] insane
people love that if you pick up these
[ __ ] odds i agree
right you get a damage buff it
encourages you to stick with your
teammates and not solo stuff it
encourages teamwork
and so for example if you include that
into the general grenade launcher
loophole now that wendigo has been
sunset
right that kind of stuff is what you
want to go with and the same with
breakneck
breakneck spin sunset why is break next
perk not in the on or
right holes that's a that's a sad loss
you know this is this is already i
already could figure out that their
thought process
part of the reason why sun setting
exists also is because
in their mind they feel dumb tops they
create two good weapons in their mind
that they feel we use as a crutch so
that sun setting is the way for them to
get it out of the little pool
without having to nerf the sandbox i'm
not gonna say it's lazy
i'm just saying from a design standpoint
i can tell why they do certain things
and i can i will
yeah i was like i will fully agree we
had this crazy like knock down drag out
when it came to sunsetting he and i did
i know a lot of people you were just
like me as well you're like old video
like sunsetting
hell yes bring it on because in our
heads you take old stuff away you're
gonna give me new cool stuff in its
place
right now that's not there they're not
fulfilling that ball
that's the huge problem of the donning
an avalanche is back i'm like i have my
feeding frenzy rampage why the hell am i
going to go grind for another one
just because it's old but it is the
exact same weapon
why and you can even introducing right
so even introducing
one new perk would not make me want to
go and roll for that unless
avalanche could roll with something like
killing uh killing
uh tally if it could roll with killing
tally that'd be
they know how these perks sit in
sandboxes
they've had a very long time to see how
these perks work in sandboxes it's not
like it's a new thing
they've been able to try and balance it
for a very long time
killing tally isn't that ridiculous it's
basically just rampage on steroids right
right right well killing
is like reconstruction just all at once
you just get a crap 10 ammo
yeah i mean what about like what if your
shadow price had as you
said whatever what is it over what is
the breakneck perk
overflow oh with uh oh no it's rampage
with
uh it's like extra rampant yeah what is
it
it's like rampage but the fire rate gets
faster
on slot what if your shadow price from
nightfalls
could drop with that you would live in
there
yeah i would live in nightfalls
that's the idea is like absolutely
they've toyed with some of these perks
the seasonal nature of these perks
allows them to
be after a certain period so they can
experiment and say this one was too much
but we only stuck with it for a year
or they could balance you know they're
doing stuff faster now
things like i want to see these types of
things like when i unfo
you're excited about shadow price which
actually surprised me a little bit but
just because you like the weapon
but when i saw three old weapons from d1
comeback for nightfall
pinnacle pursuit weapons i was not
overly excited about
three old d1 weapons i am
i'm curious i am right because
there is two auto rifles
within destiny 2 that i like bear in
mind i was
strictly either fatebringer or
an auto rifle user in d1 there was no
exception to this
it was it was either arminius d whoa
armenia's d
yeah arminius d was the [ __ ] one with
rodeo and surrounded
oh boy amazing so you use that you have
um atheon's epilogue
or you have shadow price slash hack and
hatchet
all of those auto rifles apart from
arminius d fall under
one gun model which is cuboid
aru which is a blue in destiny 2 which
i've been asking for to be a legendary
version because it's
nice amazing cuboid is my favorite it's
a myth or a rifle in destiny
yeah like i got that and i'm like this
thing is so good
i don't want like i got it in the
beginning of the campaign i don't want
to not
use this anymore i always make a new one
always make a new one but that's the
thing
that and kvastov and pushing into steel
feather repeater
they're the three nicest auto rifles in
destiny in destiny 2 specifically
so the fact that cuboid is coming back
as a shadow price
from d1 which is basically the same gun
except with a faster fire rate right
that to me gets me excited but my thing
is
right okay yeah sure it's an old gun but
it is
a very very good gun and we know that
those gun models look nice
within destiny 2. yeah sure we would
like new stuff
but at the end of the day it's also you
know
there's a lot of times when new stuff
comes around everyone's just like oh we
don't like it so it's like oh well what
do the community like let's [ __ ]
actually please them for once
let's give them stuff that we know that
they like
so do you think the adept i guess we'll
have to see how the trials weapons go
do you think that the block nature of
these weapons are going to be worth
doing grand masters
right so here's the thing right if you
can roll
the likes of these guns in the adept
version in the nightfall
and you can get the likes of a rampage
overflow
version of shadow price right and then
you can get onslaught
as a a debt mod if that is something
that you can do
and you can get onslaught to attach onto
that making your rampage insane
and then also making it so that your
overflow is kicking in so every time
you're walking over special armor your
fire rate's getting faster and faster
and faster
that sounds fantastic does that not does
that not tickle your pickle
that doesn't that does tickle my pickle
but when we talk about the trials
weapons being is like
the adept range mod is 10 more range or
the adept magazine is 40 mag but like
less stability that's all we know about
adept mods right now
if it was what you're talking about
absolutely that sounds fantastic because
i'm changing the way those weapons feel
by doing a pain in the ass activity and
then when i get out the other side
i am a bit more powerful when i'm done
with it if i have a little bit more
range or a little bit more
only if it is only the fraction and
because
they've said they're going to be
introduced in more depth mods so that's
what i'm hoping
we end up talking like and and you know
it is something
that i will be bringing up because it is
it is something something you're ready
to discuss the juice needs to be worth
the squeeze i think that's what we're
getting into
yeah but that's the thing that's the
thing right i'm not gonna go into detail
but they
know how we feel about it especially in
the last one which is why the luke thing
made me [ __ ]
burst the way that i did because they
know exactly how we feel about this game
they know exactly what it is that we
want
they went through extensive discussion
with me
specifically i was potentially the most
vocal at that
not even gonna sugarcoat that i was like
the most vocal
apart from one other person and
we were bombarding them with this [ __ ]
because they were showing us it and it's
like
right that is not what we want this is
what we want that's what
this is what we want we want this change
we want they've done this way we
and you know
the thing that i took away from it was
they said
they're listening with it and yeah
that's the bungee thing but the main
thing was
bungee devs that were there i'm gonna
say
completely agreed with everything that i
said good
and that's the thing because we were
saying it should be done this way it
should be done that way
and they said we feel soon yeah good no
no
and listen at the end of the day let me
let me get into this because i don't get
a chance to talk about that
this part is very important to me um
what you said in reference to the uh
summit meetings is very important and as
much as we're giving them
a hard time you know we have to give
them
credit few developers will
welcome their community into their doors
the fact that they even have it i know
developers i i i podcast outlaw podcast
and we talk they don't even take uh
their feedback on patch notes from the
community like they won't even the
community like this is horrible we hate
it
so what deal with it play the game like
and they won't change anything and
so i am thankful that bungie is
open-minded
and has that level of a relationship
with the community where they have
people like yourself and others come in
who are the top content creators awesome
let's get to the to the media today oh
i'm with you okay
i'm with you like when i when i when i
read
absolute look i love you but when i read
that
it it it rubbed me wrong it i it did not
sit well with me
it does not tickle your pickle it did
not tickle my pickle
sorry chad said it she said it i said it
we all had to get it out there
so we got to do it but it's like here
here's the thing
you said sunsetting we said okay we
understand
right but then you're reissuing the old
stuff right
you know you said you know you're
listening and and you know you're gonna
renewed focus on the pvp
you see where pvp is now right you know
there's all these things that are being
promised
and not delivered so and also you just
said
we are introducing the vault right we're
taking this stuff away we're going to
revamp it you know you're going to get
we're going to take these strikes
we're going to take these maps we're
going to take these weapons
like you're taking you've been taking
this whole time
right this is a game that we spend money
on so now when you talk about
oh we're gonna you know we're looking at
the current structure you know we see
stasis and
we see this thing and that's the
evolution but we're gonna take
away again so other supers that you know
what we're gonna have to make tough
choices
and when you hear about nova warping
like as a warlock i'm terrified
i am terrified the warlock classes
if you look at the solar class itself
as a whole solar class is the most
difficult to go with
they're there in a bind right you got
the well which is the ultimate support
class blessings the whole bit
you know what i'm saying you have an
aerial movement class that is very
superior with a range
melee top tree dawn blade you got bottom
tree
on dawn blade which is amazing with the
super regeneration and stuff like that
like these are kind of distinct
styles here's the thing that i
that are specifically said because yeah
it did get brought up
um because you know we were asking about
stasis that was a big feedback point
but specifically when we asked which is
why
this whole luke thing has pissed me off
so much
specifically
it's one of those where i went can we
use well because it got mentioned about
the state the subclass is getting
you know the revamp like yeah
specifically got said
can we uh will we be getting the light
subclasses
changed to the way that stasis is
alright
and we set and then when have we got an
example and it was like could you use
well with celestial fire and icarus dash
and they went yes okay and then
to read a couple of weeks later oh yeah
luke has turned round and gone
no we're not doing that was like a big
[ __ ] middle finger and it was like
well
i don't [ __ ] trust you now if you're
gonna say to me
we've we're gonna do this we're gonna do
that these ideas that you've got yes
they're amazing we've already been
talking about this in the background
you have our word and then to hear luke
say the complete opposite contradicting
thing
what a week and a half later right yeah
that doesn't sound like that's gonna be
shaking
no absolutely absolutely look i'm with
you
that that does not sound good i i'm not
in those rooms that you are in
and if these things are being said then
that's we just got to call aways that's
deception
right we can't sugarcoat if that if
that's not if you told us one thing and
then you come out and you say something
else
again i'm the only thing i read that's
how i read the context of
luke's thing is that they're in this
he's in this toying around
phase and you know they're thinking
about it so
i'm not trying to defend them i'm just
trying to know how i read it okay
but you look at the way it was like
mentioning sunsetting
they said we're toying around with
sunset right no you're right you're
right
not long before and then it happened
sunset got announced
right and then they also said oh we're
working on transmog
transmog gets announced a couple of
months later right this
luke fantasyland as he calls it is not
so much
fantasyland because you mentioned the
video
likes yeah it's like the greasy articles
he would not mention it to these news
articles if it wasn't already getting
worked on
you listen you could be very right you
could be very well here's the thing and
that's what worries me
now but here's this is where we have the
power this is
and i agree with you you know when
generally when companies do that
it's a setup for about what's about to
happen right
and you're right like that generally is
what happened here's the thing
i am seeing so much pushback from
all of you guys and we're a unified
front on this
and the thing about destiny that i love
is again
i go back to vanilla d2 and things that
is worse i would say curse of osiris
probably with lowest point at that point
and we were in a double primary meta we
were in all this awful
stuff and the community said
no you have gone too far
we are not playing your game you do not
listen
we're out i saw remember the videos
everybody made a video yo
i'm out i saw the video
so it again there's so much you can push
your community
before they say all right you know what
with the shenanigans and then moving the
goalposts and all this
so again this seems to be the unifier as
i look around twitter
i shout out to aston cross shout out to
you shout out
everybody say yo this super stay i cut
the line
here i quote you this is where you can
what's the thing though here's the thing
let's get it
how many times do we have to hit this
point before it's like
[ __ ] hell no i mean you got
like that you've got the ones launched
and then you've got you know
you know literally just before taking
king everyone's like absolutely [ __ ]
sake
taking king comes out then we have the
huge drop before right everyone's like
oh for [ __ ] sake
you've got my divine comes out it is
[ __ ] amazing they know exactly what
it is that we want
d2 comes out everyone's like i'm not
[ __ ] playing anymore because this is
a [ __ ] hot pile of garbage
and then a [ __ ] curse comes out
everyone [ __ ] leaves
one man comes out and it's got a little
sprinkle
the whisper mission whisper everyone has
said
we want the likes of whisper we want
zero mission type stuff we want stuff
that's secret in the background that
people can go and explore and once it's
found people can blitz through it get
these [ __ ] awesome weapons
right right since then that's not
happened
like yeah forsaken is [ __ ] bomb
diggity
yeah sure it was huge it was taxing yeah
you've got the team that's working on it
but again yes you're you've got this
seasonal model
that you know it works to an extent but
you've got the likes of season of dawn
which is working you've got season of
opulence
which works right every other season
specifically horrible the biggest ones
that i can think of right
are shadow keeps launching
and now we're having the exact same
situation as shadow keeps launch
this year but worse
in terms of the fact that the content
is being forcefully drip fed and
it's a case of just making players try
and cling on for as much as physically
possible
i know personally a lot of people are
logging in for the first day
seeing it seeing there's nothing new to
do or it's a [ __ ] tedious mediocre
task
and they'll go and do that and then
they're like okay well i'm coming off
now
i think and is that
really what they want their players to
feel when they log in
like that disappointment or i agree with
that
and if the answer is yes then i'm sorry
but
you you're [ __ ] letting the player
base down right and here's the problem
the problem and again i'm not making
excuses
me and e have had this discussion
constantly and
what like seasons or expansions or yeah
i know you're going
we've had this day and you know what's
so funny
i've literally switched positions with
you oh yeah i think we
pretty much flipped yeah we flipped
because what's happened is
i realized this when
activision was there we did not
realize there's always two sides to a
divorce that's how i look at this thing
right when parents break up you only
hear about one side daddy did he's evil
activists
he did this he did that the problem what
we're realizing is yeah but daddy also
gave you the resources
like a high moon like a vicarious
visions to be able to do
and help out on war mind able to do a
season of opulence they're going to have
raids
every single season so the problem with
them is
resource wise they have not proved on
their own that they can maintain this
seasonal model
let's be honest with the content not
enough it's not enough for the hardcore
for us guys
we're gonna blaze out so i've now at
this realization
where i am now playing destiny like this
new expansion it comes out i get
everything i need to get
i do everything i need and before he
would tell you you i'm guilty of this
i would be angry where's the content
what's going
on i've done everything they need to go
back to expansion
this season model sucks they have proven
to be
they cannot maintain this content
structure
i i've seen enough evidence with the
with the amount except for expansion
expansion they're fine they got the
whole year they culminate to a september
you know boom and we only get one right
now which is interesting but it's cool
that's what they've proven to me that
they can do and my new thing is i said
you know what
i'm not gonna fight it no more this is
what you're capable of when you go
through your periods of not being
interesting
or time gaining stuff for the purpose of
waiting
for two weeks down the road then
something's gonna unlock
i'll be playing um over here i'll be
playing cyprus oh i'll be playing until
the end
i'll be playing you should've said like
that's my new thing like literally
as bad as the taken king's drought was
right
there is a reason taken king is
considered the best expansion
of all time and it's because the content
was
that good yeah sure people had the
drought
but that that drought still talk see
that's my argument
within a couple of weeks to hit that's
my argument against eve with d1 versus
d2
that's my argument that's why i feel d
was maybe like a month and a half two
months before
like people started you know like
starting to realize
they did hard mode they held they had so
much power like exotic swords and stuff
well here's the thing as well with the
exotic swords they still talk a little
bit to do
but right here's the thing
when the [ __ ] did black spindle show up
that was in the background no one
mentioned that i just [ __ ] showed up
one day and it was like oh my god i was
fighting
[ __ ] that was so well done so well yeah
well you look at that and it's like
right okay so yeah sure
it is a lot and it is fine as long as
right so here's the thing i would be
perfectly happy with that drought right
over drip feed rip feed is soul crushing
because you're there and you're like
each drip you're sat there and you're
like
i want more but it's not it's not it's
not even i want more
at this point it's i want [ __ ]
something right
because every week i'm logging in and
i'm like okay pinnacles right
yeah yeah [ __ ] that i get and some
people i've seen at last point yeah i'll
give it right back to you
i know i'm talking a lot um i've seen
some kind shout out to um
what's the homie um italian i've seen
some content say you know what
i'm only coming in for the expansion
yeah i've seen people say it there's
like the season model is not for me
and i think i i think i'm in the same
boat with yeah i think that
i'm not i'm not completely off of it
because i still love the game enough
that i want to jump in and see
like i can't pull myself completely away
from it
but i i'm in a new space though that
when i'm not happy or i'm not
well i'm on board i've done i pretty
much it's one of those things where i'm
what i've done
all the important things i need to do i
got my limit i got i got
almost all my god rolls i just got cloud
strike you know once i get to that point
where i got everything out of that
season or whatever
then i fall back and i'm like okay i'll
see you when you
introduce that's the point so why
why would expansions be a bad show
because we're doing that with seasons
anyway yeah there's more seasons to do
well if you condense all three seasons
into literally one big expansion in the
september and then you've got
all of the whole year's worth of content
to play through
it will take you a little longer than a
week
to get through it and people will
potentially be happy with that because
then you go right okay
i've got a full year to go through a
year's worth of content
right you can i can go with my own pace
if i want to burn through
all of the [ __ ] years story lines and
then we start working on end game and
all that kind of stuff
then yeah sure maybe space out halfway
through the year that a second raid or
something like that or an extra secret
mission shows up
not so much drip feed don't announce it
we'll just
put it in the background at some point
and then players will discover it and
they'll always start they're like when
the [ __ ] did this show up and then
it excites everyone again it's the same
with like
doing um the wrath of the machine
with outbreak and then it's like you
know like they've got these little
puzzles you've got these community
events that you could do
every every quarter you could bring out
a community event which gets
its community excited again yeah sure
there will be people that burn through
the content
but they will do that anyway so where is
the loss
in just putting out the whole thing and
just going
here you go here it is have fun
i think by themselves they just can't do
it i just i just
that's my gut i i love them as a studio
but they're saying they can't put that
much together at once
i don't know or the expansion drop okay
then what would be the middle ground
of we don't need these baby drip feed
seasons but what if it's a halfway
what if it's the expansion that's got
some extra
and then the six month window you get
like
you know that's when you get oh you guys
i mean you're back to basically the
taking key
you're back to crota's end you go
actually i would really like
i would prefer it like six months you'd
like take what you can do in six months
i would love it then you do the smaller
little
that would make the two seasons right so
you could do so
yeah two seasons in one that would give
you more stuff to do
and it would make it yeah sure it would
give you
you know less of the the gaps between
but it'd feel less time
gated it would be like here's a bunch of
stuff to play with instead of
oh here's a little bit and then we'll
give you in a couple of months i love
you too you got
bless your hearts but let me tell you
what's going on
we gotta talk real down numbers
engagement battle pass remember when
that was introduced
get that little thing and you buy for
ten dollars they're making money
with this seasonal model every time in
the
cosmo cosmetics come out what if the
seasons are 20 bucks instead of 10.
i'm with your content-wise i just don't
see them
doing it because even though we hate
this model
they're making money they're they're
tripping us with everything with this
that battle pack all this extra stuff
and you saw how aggressive tess has been
you know said as far as the the her
suits and her cosmetics and ornaments
being way
better than you get in game
for forever we've seen that [ __ ] of
heresy has pissed me off since then
can't stand it yeah
i mean i hate to be captain corporate
here but that's
what they're doing and that's the
discussion like i would not
i would not say it as such a bad thing
if
if there was more to do each time
if you would support right so here's the
thing if you were to
as as we've all basically said so
like e um you know you're saying like
condense the two seasons into
one in every six month cycle right doing
that
as literally including that ever verse
wise as well
or maybe when the new season comes out
maybe just swap around the eververse
because then you know it's not bringing
out new content it's just a case of oh
okay we'll give the episode a little
refresh every like three months or
something like that and then bring out
the expansion every six
that would kind of encourage people to
go to eververse and they wouldn't have
to
go too far in terms of doing a big drop
they wouldn't have to work on marketing
and all that kind of [ __ ] because it's
literally just a case of here's a new
arm set in the upper burst you can [ __ ]
around with that in three months time
i feel but like see what new reddit said
this is what people say
so well read it they did the math one
season worth three months
of silver purchase brings in at least 10
million
i was like i would love to know who did
the math on that yeah
they make they're making bank bro i i i
know for
i mean when these aren't listen i am
very guilty when that dawning came out
i spent silver on the on the on the
warlock said
i i i got the new xenophage ornament
i got the new oh what you call it just
give me a dollar
on how much bro i spent i blew 50 easy
i bought like five ornaments like
dawning is my favorite thing
i do i do do that sometimes if there is
specifically something
but the likes of the but the likes of
the season pass right
so like i did it for the hawk moon
ornaments right because it's it's
[ __ ] hockman you know i've got the
gun forever it's there
but in terms of the season part like i
there's nothing from dawning
or the other verse this season this
afternoon
apart from a finisher or something like
that that has made me go
yes but that's because probably because
it's you know it's my personal tastes
um so i look at the i look at the door
and i go it's too fancy for me
well but then i look at the finisher
which is the gun on the back
there you go okay so i will go for that
because i'm a sucker for finishes
then you got the new dances and you got
the thing you got to do ghosts
everywhere yeah everybody i see i use dj
i use dj
we buy this stuff that was like but at
the same time
hands over fist on us with this stuff
this is where the real money's coming in
is evan's test i i got to the point now
when
i look on the reset to see what's going
on
with tests i'm guilty as john and that's
what that's
their business model right now sadly
it's the drip to make you log in
and then while you're there some people
check every verse
and that's easy no i know but i know and
that's the point where it's like
they need to find some way to balance
like this
cool eververse stuff versus
the drip feed of like as you said it's
like it's killer when you i want to know
what's gonna happen with
crow and spider and i'm like but i'm
gonna go play demon souls and cyberpunk
until
i figure it out and it's just like
that's what kills me it's like and i
don't
know how to and that's the thing is i
have the answer of how it
is how for them to keep us engaged
to spend the money in every verse to
always keep logging in
but also not just piss me off when i
don't get anything
when i log in i'm like man i told people
they like it i said they should i was
hoping the microsoft they'll go they
need a publisher they need
that person to be able to get resources
that's why that's something i agree
they do i mean activision may not be the
best
marriage you know what i'm saying but we
saw the level of content we was getting
when they were there
if microsoft had bought them right and
allowed them to retain their
individuality with destiny allow destiny
to still remain multi-platform
right and they get the new ip or
whatever it is matter whatever
right yeah here's the thing as long as
it is
primarily a funding based thing
yeah and obviously like a profit based
you know relationship with microsoft
over
decisions that go on within the game
absolutely yeah because if you would
never
make outside the country budget would
never make a deal when anyone comes in
that studio
and trying to control that board they
they especially
since they're now free yeah they that's
that's why they're asking
listen i know things behind the scenes
the asking price the reason why the deal
has not happened
they have been in talks multiple times
the reason why it's not happening is
bungie's asking prices a bit
high and granted because they're never
going to put themselves in the situation
they went with the first time with
microsoft
as well as the activision thing they
want creative control
so their price is okay if you want us
that's just now here's the thing
they do have a decent enough
relationship where you still see
this special deal where you see in a
game pass that's a special
they put their entire new season
in game pass that's a big deal so their
buddy buddy
right that buddy buddy right now the
issue comes down to if
we want the destiny that we want they
need to be acquired they cannot do it on
their own
they've proven yeah the season model
they just can't keep it up well i mean
even joe blackburn straight up said it's
like you're talking about the
the loop pool is too small we're like
yeah it's too small and you ripped
three quarters of it away and he's like
well we got to build up the team i'm
like
okay so literally what you just told me
is the next three seasons
yup we ain't gonna have nothing we ain't
gonna have [ __ ] because they they just
they're just hiring now
right yeah they're hiring now they have
to develop
these like bungee gunsmiths so they can
make these
iconic what because i mean you pick up
what is that the
it's the void scout rifle from season
the hunt i fired that thing i'm like
it's unique sounding like every one of
their guns is that peaceful they're very
easy
why is it not stasis oh there's so much
like
there's there's no spaces in the game
don't even get me started on that though
okay
i cannot go too far into that yeah let's
let it leave it lower
yeah all i can say is hopefully that
grows
is all we can say but just the idea that
like
they have these bungee gunsmiths that
they want to
like grow they want to nurture their you
know new employees
but that still tells me i'm not seeing
anything now until witch queen
which queen is potentially a promise but
like what is the time frame and
turnaround of what's gonna happen
we don't know and that's where you said
some people only play expansions
and it is again what is their financial
their
bandwidth between all the people in
their studio and then
the expectations of the community and
they need to figure out some way to
spend the money to hire and balance it
yeah and it's
it's a lot for them right now they're
independent but it's
it's a struggle and they're doing the
business piece with the drip right now
and some of us just i want to buy and
play my dad it's like mobile games i
don't play mobile games on my phone
because i can't sorry for this one
doesn't happen very often on stream
[ __ ] stand them listen i don't curse
very often so
destiny feels like a mobile game at the
moment and it's [ __ ] destroying it
just going to say it yeah but for the
hardcore guys
and gals like us you know
that's not what we're used to we're in
this weird position
but we love this game we'll blaze this
content out and don't get me wrong we
enjoyed it right we had a great time
deep stone crib is amazing
a lot of this stuff is really fantastic
but the the days of it being this
super hardcore game that's gonna let us
you know
put months and months and weeks and time
you know in
i've changed lives yeah i i came to that
conclusion
when when season of the drifter and all
that stuff and the black armory when
they did all that
i told you i was not happy he knew i was
very disgusted
and i was like oh this is the new this
is what we're doing i was like i'm not a
fan of this season stuff
and you know i just learned that okay
this is what it is then they made the
announcement they leave
okay everybody's like yeah they left
activate it's gonna be a new day
and it's the same thing as far as the
drip fee stuff it's less
yeah it's yeah where they're at their
best is like i said
expansion stuff when they have more time
out again that's resources that's
bandwidth
when they do they here as well right
they're coming out with these you know
the the comet expansions right
yeah which are the big september
releases
now yeah we are used
to the taking king and
forsaken and stuff like that
and you look at the backing that they
had during those
and
i personally
cannot see destiny playing
destiny keeping its player base
with the current seasonal drip feed the
way they are going
interesting it is a sad reality well i
personally
cannot see it there are more people from
what i've seen
like beyond light comes out it is
it's pretty disappointing um in terms of
one like how like how how grand it looks
at first and you get your hands on it
and you realize it's actually really
light and thin and it's just marketed to
look
significantly more grand than it is um
and then you look at the game
in its general sense and if it is
specifically the likes of
folks that will play for maybe
an hour or so every few days a week or
something like that
and you see those guys they'll log
they'll log in they'll do what they do
and then they'll come off
right and if you see that and all the
hardcore drops off all the content
creators go away because they've got
nothing to do
then there's no one really advertising
the game
and then people aren't going to be
really bothered
you see them all drop off the only
people that do log on is like you
[ __ ] joe blogs that [ __ ] logs in
there's literally like an hour maybe he
spends a couple a bit
but in the grand aspect of things surely
the more money is made when you've got a
bigger happier player base who is there
happy to support you
we like the likes of the whisper mission
we like the likes of zero i'm going to
reiterate that
and they have said that our
contributions to every verse
pay for stuff like that right now
we are always especially after the act
division split
being announced we have always said we
are fine playing
like paying eververse if it leads to
[ __ ] like that
especially since they said that it pays
for something but they did say that
yesterday
right you're right they specifically
said it and then
for those to turn around
and then give us the likes
of what we are getting
it feels very very
very much like
a backhand because it's like we're all
like yes
bungie we will support you we will give
you funding
in terms of eververse we will buy these
expansions we will buy these collector's
editions we will do this
because we want to see you succeed we
know what you are capable of
absolutely and then they don't
right right and then they make these
decisions that
you know in terms of the the subclass
thing going back to it they have it in
terms
of yeah but they're discussing that
you're scaring us
all this stuff feels like
it's not for the player base like they
always say we care about you we're
listening this that and the other
but then the way they go
right is like actions speak louder than
words
right now and right now the actions are
not matching it feels like they're
telling everyone to [ __ ] off and wait
for the new ip to come out
that's how it feels i was i
i have had that weird sinking suspicion
as well to be completely honest like
you're
no it's like there's this weird
christopher barrett's out there working
on something
yeah he's the other head of
matter whatever code name who knows
whatever it's like that's the rumors or
whatever it's supposed to be
yeah and it feels like
the weapon loot pool being smaller the
you know the scale of what we got this
time around
the destiny vault is easier to manage
for a smaller team potentially
how small the team is working on destiny
2
is a question we will never get an
answer to but i am because
if we've got right if we've got seven
years of this [ __ ]
i'm sorry but the game's going to die
before that
we don't our community
would not be as passionate about destiny
and [ __ ] right up their [ __ ]
[ __ ] about all this
if we didn't give a [ __ ] we would just
not play
and that's the frustrating bit because
we all want to see destiny do well
absolutely we're all so supportive we're
all like they're that they
know what the destiny community is
capable of in terms of you know
you bring out a community event we will
grant they have a living [ __ ] out of it
this is the first time i have not got
involved in a community event you've got
all these charities that they bring out
and they're all like oh yeah look how
[ __ ] amazing these guys are
but then all these people that are
raising the money
all these people that are donating the
money all this kind of stuff
these people will not be around if the
game continues in its current
state here's the thing and again i i get
it i get the frustration
the problem is they still have the best
gun play
they still have the best raid as far as
any end game and kick activity as far as
console gaming
yeah they still do they still have
arguably the best soundtrack team
in the gaming um you're like that is a
hill i will die on
i'm dying on that so deep stone lullaby
like
when that hit for me the first time that
it's there's so many times the music
there's iconic music and games destiny
is on that list this is one of the
questions
you have this formula of greatness that
when we play and it is at its best
there's nothing better oh yeah 100
yeah so the problem is in order for them
to
lose and to officially be out of there
someone has to come along and knock it
out
and it's we're here six years
with the ups and downs and the bad
seasons and the good seasons and the
good expanded
through all of this stuff that we're mad
at they're still
here so again i just don't see it
changing
they're at this point where they have
like this amazing
thing right it doesn't it's not always
operating at its best
all the time but there's nothing else
like it
everything division anthem
we got outright is about to come up next
that looks good
um
no it's not going to be a living there's
a lot of people who have tried the live
service model and they all
keep failing so bungie has done
something
very special shout out to as well who is
part of the community
that made this special which is always
one of those things that we'll fall back
to is
you said gun play music raids in-game
that stuff is great
but also on the other side is they sit
there and they ask when they worked with
activision and they talked to
diablo developers how do you want your
customer to
leave your game right do you want them
to leave
satisfied or and not even blue balls in
this case or just like
not great less satisfying just seem to
be fitting there but
satisfied with blue balls great
companies right now
right now people come on they see
there's nothing to do
they've come off and they're
disappointed yeah and that's not how you
want someone
to leave and but that's like that's and
that's why we're literally
we've been at this for shout out to our
longest podcast
she's she's proving her endurance right
now 32 hour stream she's like
four hour podcast this is nothing um but
that's
that's their tough balance i didn't even
realize it had been that long with yeah
we were rocking
ass and taking names um yeah it's like
you see division two you mentioned like
and then fell off a cliff avengers had
its own issues anthem had its own issues
cyberpunk is uh example for a whole lot
of developers for a whole lot of reasons
but if like but and that's like
they have a weird balance to walk around
and i don't envy any of them right now
that's the key is like
we the community will be ravenous
for they could throw two years of crap
at us and people like ob kitty cat over
here will burn through
two two years of stuff in that two
months because
the hardcore will go crazy now how it's
delivered
how it like gets to us but drip feeding
in a story is like
it's like trying to read a book and you
get one page
in that book in the mail once a week bro
right so that's the part and i hate it
your journey
really your journey has fl it's so
interesting but it's like what kills me
more is the stories are even more
compelling than ever
and i think that's what hurts me more is
the stories are
in such a good place with we've got
clovis
going on with elsie and anna we've got
the darkness which we know you know
aramis is frozen and not dead you've got
all of these things you've got savithoon
sitting in the wings we've got the first
mention of zebu or wrath
we've got the sabbath thing makes sense
to be drawn out
but the the oh the [ __ ]
i was like don't break anything by the
way don't indicate yeah no
the exo stranger and stuff not like
you know how we can go around and
explore and like we can find this thing
relating to clover so we can find that
thing
and she's following us around the system
we're doing that story
and we can go through that as fast as
possible yet we've got the zebra raf
thing going on in the background which
makes sense because zebra
raph is working on our own terms but
when it's going to speak to a vendor and
you've got to wait a [ __ ] week
uh why am i playing on all words right
now
for example right the whole what was it
when we got saint out
right oh yeah that was potentially the
best storyline each week a different
thing
shows up and yeah sure it makes sense
because the portal is only showing up
every week
that makes sense but then the final bit
right this was really [ __ ] jarring
for me
we go in we get saint we save him he
goes a long way around
but then the cutscene happens he comes
out the portal in our timeline and
doesn't show up for another week
yes like no talk to osiris no bro hug no
no no what the [ __ ]
that was done that they they had a
perfect journey they ended it
horribly yeah with long lasting and it's
this and it's
and i get that the you know there's like
like like the tree thing from
um last season
nothing that that that that pacing was
really good because it was each week it
was the more corruption
and the same with the ascendant uh the
ascendant realm and the dream and city
dynamic
where every week the corruption gets
worse and yeah sure
but that's when it's every week right
when it's every week and it's something
that changes which is
outside of our influence
whereas the likes
of you know just
everything that's going on at the moment
is just it feels like it's drawn out and
drip-fed but not for the sake
not for the sake of the story beats
being out of our control
it's just being weird it's just being
dripped for the sake of drips yeah yeah
you know you know what a wise man told
me ovie
yeah he said you have these great other
games
that you could play yeah that was me
that's the thing that's right here's the
thing you could play he said you could
come back i've been playing other stuff
and that's it
that's what a wise man told me he's the
thing
i was talking to my main thing is i
love destiny i don't have another tattoo
of another game
on me right there is a reason i love
destiny as much as i
do right so
i don't want to have to go and play
these other games
all the time you're in defense you got
to come to where i'm at now
see where you this was b last year
episodes ago i was like i don't want to
play this is my
favorite game nothing gives me this joy
i
feel you and then what i had to do is
when i was upset i had to
hurt it off and try something else
and then you know what happened after a
while i started to miss it
you know what i said okay and now i'm
ready to come back
you know that's turning off and wanting
to go back
a day or two or something like that mine
is i come off destiny
and i instantly want to be on and the
problem is i get frustrated because
there's nothing for me to do when i do
go on
and then i'm sat there and i'm like well
i just don't want to [ __ ] play
anything then
oh come on you can't go you can't not
play anything no more
yeah but that's that's the thing that's
why i'm like it like i've started doing
just
just just chatting streams recently like
in the past
week the past few days actually
because there is nothing to do and
that's the thing i want to be able to
log into the game so that i can
play the game which the objective of the
game is for fun
and to have fun of course i don't want
to
i don't want to log in and for it to
feel like a [ __ ] chore
it's not giving you fun right now so
remember when you said did you like
these great single player
amazing games that's what i am working
on but i'm waiting for them to come out
as well there we go
there we go a wise man told me this it
made my life
so much better i don't even get angry at
destiny
oh you're not doing what i want you to
do right now okay i see i'll be back
in two weeks when the drip feed is
finished and then
i'll pick up right where i left off and
until then i got these amazing other
games
i'm just playing and having fun and
since then my stress level has been down
everything's been great i love finishing
games i beat ghost to shiva
i did all this amazing things like
trust me it's just okay i know i'm being
silly
but the reality is right now just the
way they're structured it's just a drip
feed
it's not going to satisfy a person like
you you you
you are one of the very best in the
community you are
an extremely skilled player you are an
amazing sherpa
right you are going to blaze through
this little drip feed stuff in days
you know what i mean so you will have to
do things to keep you occupied so that
you don't
lose love for it and just come back when
you're when they have stuff for you
that's actually engaging that's all i
would advise to you mm-hmm
wise man you know see that that's that
that is the thing like that is what i
want to do
i want to be able to like you know just
turn the game off and go and do
something like back for blood it's the
most fun i've had in a while
um but again that's the alpha it's only
out for four days i'm gonna be [ __ ]
around so somehow chat mentioned like
dark souls three and i was like you
strike me as somebody who would
do you enjoy those type of games yeah do
you drive
here's the thing right i enjoy dark
souls very much so we were playing dark
souls 3 right
um and it's the same for the avengers
game
and it's the same for subnautica and
here's the thing no other game
grips me the way destiny does i don't
know
or maybe though in some of them language
so the light so the like of dark so the
like of
destiny you know the laws there it's all
that it's grip me and
i i love the game the thing is i go on
to dark souls i play it for a little bit
yeah sure it is it is it is punishing
and it's really [ __ ] good and it
stretches you the [ __ ] out when you're
trying to
learn [ __ ] but at the same time
when it reaches a certain point of
frustration
and i've tried logging off for the day
coming back at a day the day after and i
still can't beat that thing for three
days
i'm just kind of like okay i'm not
enjoying i'm gonna be on destiny
don't jump on destiny nothing to do on
destiny
[ __ ] this i'm coming off and then
and then it's a case of log on next day
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
nice uh we're gonna try and go on dark
souls again
they'll start failing i'm like oh okay
avengers is out let's go and play in
avengers
so we do [ __ ] a huge thing big of a
big thing of avengers we hit a
gap and it's dark souls all over again
so i'm like i'm going to go on destiny
then try and lighten the mood a little
bit
that's [ __ ] all to do
there's only so much of a game that i
can talk and i don't like the likes of
some well
i really like subnautica but it's kind
of it's too much of a time investment
for me
okay um minecraft again it's one of
those where it's
you know it's very very very time
consuming and for me
looking at the fun i'm getting out of it
compared to the
ratio of how much i'm like so the fun to
time
investment ratio is
it's tough you can get way more time
consuming than i'm getting enjoyment out
of it
no and that's the thing like i look at
like the way destiny has been when it's
been at its greatest
and it's frustrating when
i know what it's capable of and it is
able to satisfy
that hunger for great content
and stuff like that but at the same time
it is now at the point where i'm like
well i don't have these other games
because i've either completed them or
i'm frustrated and can't be bothered or
it's going to make me jump on destiny
and then i'm just going to get more
pissed off at the fact that destiny is
in a [ __ ] state
and that is the cycle i'm in at the
moment which is why just
chatting and all that is kind of the way
that i've been going back for blood is
absolutely satisfying everything except
for
luke chase because as long as there was
a boss fight in there because you know
what i'm like with boss fights
yeah the horde modes and that feels what
the hive should feel like
like for [ __ ] sake to have an ogre for
[ __ ] sake it is amazing
what well i'm looking at that and i'm
like right okay so that's
that that's really it it's like okay so
when i play another game it just reminds
me how much i miss destiny
but then when i go on another game and
then get frustrated with that and jump
on destiny it just reminds me how
frustrated i am at destiny
so then i'm in this cycle of this cycle
yeah okay i'm going to come off destiny
the other thing reminds me how much i
miss it and then it just makes me pissed
off that destiny isn't a better state so
then i'm just like
well [ __ ] me i guess
[Laughter]
you're a tough spot you're the dust spot
and i was i was there
for the only thing the thing that got me
through
was just i started to really focus on my
backlog and stuff of great games that
people would tell me about and say yo
you need to play the whole you didn't
play that you didn't experience that
and i just slowly started going through
that and it was the single player stuff
and
you know i'm a big turn-based guy that
that's huge for me
i think you probably just need one more
genre that's going to help you satisfy
you during those down periods
of destiny total punishment but like
something like
immortal phoenix rising or ghost of
tsushima or yeah
like the story experience like that you
got in sea of solitude seemed like
i watched you for two minutes on a video
and i was like this thing just gave you
a gut punch
for the experience you just had i'm like
no granny you don't need to like
ball your eyes out every day that's a
bit much for anybody to go through but
like finding good story adventures to go
on even it's like hey here's a chapter
we play
and that may be your stream for a day
it's like but also the tough thing for
you is
i stream for 12 uh [ __ ] 10 to 15 i
was gonna say it's a full-time job
for you it's something you do daily like
here's the thing here's the thing i do
it for you
i don't give a burn out what i get
is lack of sleep and passing out
no no i'm good for that that is a very
rare occurrence and that's usually due
to heat
more than anything to me because like
the heat the heater gets left on or
something like that or outside is too
warm and i physically can't cool down
because we don't have
you know we don't have air con and all
that kind of stuff so it's generally
just i've got my two pieces
pcs on the sun's [ __ ] done and
someone's decided to leave the [ __ ]
heating on
and then i'm just like right okay
you know that's what takes me out
anything else
doesn't i tiredness doesn't affect me
whatsoever
um like i get it reaches a point and i'm
like okay i'm tired i'm gonna come off
but the thing about the heat thing is i
don't realize how [ __ ] tired i am
and how exhausted i'm getting from being
heat
because i'm concentrating on the fact
that i'm currently sweating my hips off
and then next thing i know i'm on the
[ __ ] floor
yes yeah 100 guys look after yourself
but my thing again it isn't burnout it's
more
the with the way that you know
the games are out at the moment the way
that they're all going towards this
mobile slow drip feed base thing
and it's not just destiny it's just most
games in general
towards that and i'm looking at it in it
in terms of a
well as someone said smiles per hour
kind of gauge
if that if that isn't keeping up with
you know
what i'm looking for then i'm kind of
getting a little frustrated at the fact
that you know
there isn't that and then when i go and
play other stuff because they're not do
well if i don't play other stuff because
it's not giving me that miles per hour
it's just reminded me how frustrated i
am with the state of destiny
and then it's a constant cycle of that
and like that's the thing like i like
being able to go oh
here is a story game we haven't played
awesome let's go jump into it like sea
of solitude we've done destiny for the
day
and then we just jump straight on see a
solitude afterwards and then it's the
same with like hellblade we did it with
that
we did and then we've you know we did uh
back for blood
um the other day and stuff like that
yeah
sure they were amazing but by the end of
it i'm like oh okay
can't wait to jump on destiny and then
instantly
instantly i'm like [ __ ]
destiny's got nothing right now and then
i'm just like oh
[ __ ] this like you know it's
gotta find a substitute that's the thing
yeah yeah yeah but that's the thing that
isn't
really a substitute at the moment i mean
i'm waiting for
um well chat's been trying to get me to
play monster hunter i'm gonna give that
a shot but the only one
the only problem is it's pretty
expensive to get into monster hunter and
play it for maybe a couple of hours and
then realize it's not for me
that is my main concern it's like do i
really want to put this much time
and effort and money into something that
i will play for maybe a couple of hours
it's why i haven't done miles morales
right because i've played the previous
spider-man
i completed the story mode the end game
wasn't my type of end game so i was like
okay i'm done
yeah look it's go you got to keep trying
it
it's out there you just got to find it
it's out there there's no doubt it's out
there
it's just right now you got you got
those destiny withdrawals it's hard to
shake i was like
you never know what games you like which
is
obviously as you said it's expensive
experimentation if you do it a lot yeah
depending on how cosmophobia was good
while i was playing that
yeah cosmophobia was good but again it's
one of those you can only do something
so many times
like right okay and that's why it's hard
so inside someone's playing through
metallica
that's like i mean that's like i was
like that's where you're saying is like
if it's a package with a start and a
finish
the problem is when you hit that finish
your first reaction is destiny
and destiny is right now for you you've
done it all
so that's the thing i don't want to
start anything
because then if i do play something i'm
going to get frustrated either
at the fact if i hit a wall within that
game and i'm like right okay i'll take a
break i'll go play destiny for a little
bit i'm gonna go on destiny and i'm like
oh
but then if i if i do the same thing
where if i complete the game and i don't
hit any walls all the way through
then i'm like okay there's my first
playthrough done
and now the experience isn't there like
yeah sure i could go and do it again on
a different difficulty but it's
not the [ __ ] insane no i don't
usually go like i'm very much uh
play something once get all the
experience go back to destiny
now here's the issue when you do that
and destiny's [ __ ]
on the time gated way
you just gotta hold out for a couple
weeks you gonna be fine
you need to probably sleep leave yeah
because is it four am there
she was like it's for him there i know
i've got youtube i've got youtube stuff
to do but that's sweet oh that's fair
but either way okay
uh i do need a way out of stick actually
yeah that's how you mentioned and this
just kind of hit me
oh yeah things are still talking over
there um
so what i wanted to do is first off say
this has been amazing
by far our longest podcast we have ever
had so thank you for joining us for this
oh anytime it's been an absolute
pleasure on our end but i wanted to say
i got more workouts to go do so
they've they've thrown some points into
chat so i'm working out
uh if you incognito can work on
some type of putting a bow on this thing
i will be back no we can
only start a little bit of the outros as
well too or whatever oh
let's go yeah he's got it he's got to do
this thing but look you know i hear what
you're saying what i was going to say is
what what else you got going on
you know as far as upcoming content-wise
things we could look out for
that you could be doing uh well um
we've obviously got the likes of back
from blood uh as chat's shown
we've got um do maternal nice which
i will be working on it's just a case of
picking the right time to do it i don't
want to start it when i'm frustrated
with everything and then
realize what it is like i'm enjoying
playing other games with doom soundtrack
on
um but it's one of those where i've got
to be in the right mindset i don't want
to start something and not really be in
the mood for it and not get
their full experience um so the likes of
like you know like sea of salt and all
that
um but there are multiple games like
that i'm waiting for
a bunch of other stuff to come out as
well okay
give me some names give me some names
would you wait for the come out uh i'm
waiting for hellblade too
nice um i'm waiting for what was the
name of the one i
retweeted it earlier
which one was it
with i'm just trying to find it they
were all the game awards they were all
announced there was um
i think it was medium something the
medium
yes that oh that's a good one horror uh
double dual
reality yeah that's the kind of [ __ ]
that i absolutely [ __ ] love so i'm
looking forward to that but that's the
thing it's all just it's all just
waiting games
um we are gonna be playing black for
blood uh later today
i'm going to be trying on the next
difficulty up um
and seeing how that feels i'm going to
be doing a youtube video very shortly
on the day one of it um
so that's pretty much what i'm going to
do after this but in terms of
stream content i'm going towards uh just
chatting i'm going to be experimenting
with different games
uh i'll log in every week if there's
something on destiny
do it i'll do a bit of shareprint all
that kind of stuff i've got three man
flawless
two-man and two-man floors to do on deep
stone
so they are the other things that i need
to do
um i'll be getting involved with any
community events if they show up
um but for the disabled future i'm
obviously going to be having a little
reject on how
i want to do things um
but you know it's something that i will
be sorting with my chat i don't do
anything independently
oh well i mean i i always if i want to
do something i will do it
i like regardless of whether chat wants
me to do it or not but i will also
you know work with what they want and if
they suggest something
i will you know if i get enough
suggestions there will be something
which will
click with me and we'll roll with it um
but you know we are
a unison me and my goons you know what
we're like
but no so i i it's generally just
figuring stuff out but mainly just like
just chatting experimenting
um and shippers and all that kind of
stuff uh 2021 i'm really gonna be
pushing
um for uh
youtube content because you know i do
this full time now so youtube
is something that i i have learned to
how to video edit
uh the past few months um so that's
pretty sick so i'm gonna be working on
that
um i've got a lot of stuff off
[ __ ] i've got a lot of stuff outside of
um
destiny and streaming that i want to be
pushing for in terms of charity work and
stuff
i i've got a lot of the bigger picture
kind of stuff
especially after these threads on
twitter and stuff right
um it's kind of opened my eyes a little
bit um
but you know there's there's a lot of
big stuff coming
um i can't really get too far into it
but no very very excited
uh if you get into that kind of stuff i
look forward to it you got stuff cooking
this is good yeah
me
obviously um i'm getting salute there
okay for coming through
great episode definitely some a lot of
heart-to-heart talks on a lot of
important subjects that we all
passionate about so that was cool and i
love
love what you do in the community you
know love helping people the passion for
the game is just tremendous
that's always cool to see and um yeah
i'll be looking out for that uh content
back for blood and all the other streams
but for me yeah probably the
final ironwork podcast of the year will
be this sunday
11 a.m eastern probably again the final
11 a.m we'll probably go back to the new
year at 1 00 p.m eastern on sunday
so catch that on animal podcast youtube
kind of like a feel-good episode just a
recap
of what's going on all year it's you
know highs and lows of the generation
stuff
we may have some people pop in people
are more than welcome to pop in so
that's also extended to you
if you're around if you wanna we gotta
have a big old zoom call and
people could just pop in it's kind of
just like a celebration thing we might
just talk
one topic which is like um cyberpunk and
what
craziness what's been going on with that
you know saying but um
yeah so like i said yeah we got that
going and um
yeah we're doing right now on
logicgaming.net we are doing our golden
lance award so it's our little version
of the game awards this is
by the the writers the gamers you know
just as far as um
you know their their technical
achievements what games they felt had
the best
you know graphics narrative sound all
that stuff and this is faster
too something one
a lot lot of votes are going in you know
so check that out
that's on loads of gaming.net right now
some of the uh the winners of
some awards are going out holly mod
where you been came in the back room
late
that's good oh brother but um yeah we
got that and then obviously you know
what i'm saying on if you like into
statues and all that good stuff
please check my brother king david he's
got the king of statues going on you can
learn about that
and of course the last word the most
likely final episode of
2020 so it's been a fantastic year um i
want to shout out to chat
first um man like you guys
just just seeing the growth and seeing
everybody in here listening to our
foolishness and
and and just the support is is really
cool to see it we've had some we've had
an amazing year
we had some amazing guests on it's
always a pleasure to do this podcast
with you
the fights the the debates the the
passion
discussions
it's a fun podcast i love to do it i
love to see it grow like to see where we
continue to go and um
yeah man it's 2020 was a good one 2020
was a good one man
2021 the sky the future's bright
we have more amazing guests like obi
katie cat
and uh just wolf discussions about this
game we love so
salute to e to cheetah love doing it man
this was definitely definitely a great
episode yeah this was more than i ever
could have expected
for trying to line this thing up with ob
katie cat and then stealing you for
better part of the day it seems like at
this point
no thank you so so much this has been a
pleasure perfect episode to go out on
the year on
your goons are amazing shout out to all
of them out there if they listen to this
or if they're in chat
um as i said earlier at the top of the
show thank you guys for
being with us for now 131 episodes and
we got
20 21 to come 2020 sucked for a lot of
reasons
yeah this was a typical highlight for
the week for us for sure and i think
quite a few of you guys as well
um oh my god that is a [ __ ] idea
from slay the mother wait hold on i'm
sorry my outro has been thrown what's
the motherland
sorry i don't know if you've ever seen
it but if i
show you this yeah does that ring any
bells
oh oh i got you oh
okay do you know do you know what it is
uh
if not i can send you a clip 750 clip
yeah give me a second let me find it
i was like our typical outro mm-hmm
yeah you know ours i was like so we got
to do that for sure
um but for me you guys will find me i
streamed for four hours
and i dropped 337 frames out of
about 337 frames out of about
500 000. so 0.1
was dropped so in the grand scheme the
internet
crossed my fingers is getting better so
more streaming you guys might find me
streaming on youtube to experiment with
that one a little bit
um hey i'm from trust me i wanted a good
connection first yeah that'll impossible
i'm like look man i told him i said to
give him a shot he's working through
this
because i have a lot of followers over
there too so the youtube still working
souls i will slowly work through
cyberpunk um
that's just gonna be a thing whether i
get a new graphics card and gets a
random upgrade in the middle or who
knows what but uh
yeah it's been an amazing year and as
all of these
awesome people with me have said this is
the last one of 2020.
um stay safe out there guys it has been
honestly ask katie about your internet
connection oh i'm sure inside out you
and i probably have some fun chats ahead
of us but
dude he may as well be on [ __ ] dial
up
both mine's not
dial up but it's really fast but really
sporadic so
i've had 25 dropped frames so it's just
not even watchable that
is a motherland yes
where in the chat um
i see it that's that's a slow one bear
in mind
it's slower wow
wow wow
that's that's something that's something
[Laughter]
all right well to ob katie cat and the
motherland this has been episode
131 the final one for 2020.
thank you guys thank you chad we're
going to go raid amaze after this home
of the vibes i'm going to send you guys
over there because you guys have all
been awesome
uh but for this episode it has been